19:6 still still internship for the top
female players in the world and once
again joined by the one hand because you
know you're going back to the pasta
she's an amazing host and we are here
today to talk about to every players of
the Athenian chess scenario former
women's go check an accent okosan if the
chest pain is going to face poor fam US
Champion and as a Tomsky what do you
think is not will bring if it's going to
be an exciting match we have first
matched very exciting it was very tight
and I really enjoyed it and I think that
we will have a lot of entertainment
today because both of the players are so
strong
Aleksandra is considered to be a big
favorite because of her rating and she
wants to play online please and so on
but I'm actually has positive score
against her in the game India has four
is in favor of an acceptance key that
includes classical record and these
games and they are over the four games
so viciously in the 14 years version
they're four times US Champion I added
the new champion Alex indicator and I
support am year's champion if she is
ready for the online challenge and it's
Angela experienced online player and it
doesn't play that often online so we
shall see how that turns out
once again we will start with a five
minute plus one second portion for one
and a half hour then we have three plus
one for an hour and a loss most exciting
for that's the toughest one I think
that's where the tables can turn and
that's where like
yeah that's going to be really excited
and I'm really happy to actually comment
I so need to end much plate but I'll
force you to play the bullet have your
own channel
that's a deal is a deal yeah all right
what what do you think what's gonna
happen today like we will have big
difference in scores or it's going to be
a level match how do you think it will
go I think it's going to be a very close
match well the experience on Wednesday
it may be that was to the extreme we are
referring to the first match of the
Women's feature championship it started
with a tie for every single segment
between Qatar in Olano and Alina
Danielle oh yeah they tied with five
plus one is three plus one and the
bullet was decided by the final gaze
well that was very very exciting the
final game actually it happened also in
the match of the Jordan confer a chemise
re-enter II it was saying that the score
was equal and the final game would
decide the winner
and that's as there was a spectacular
show as well as the first match of the
alien versus but no I think it should go
in a similar way we can mention the
meantime the predictions the smarter
just predictions that it's in favor of
alexandra yeah it is the predictions are
that Alexandra will win with one point
five to four in five minutes late
section five in half and versus three
and park in three plus one section and
bullets private half foreign half I
don't know I'm the closer and event
probability is eighty one percent for
Alexandra and nineteen percent for
Anna's a toasty but we saw Elena having
an even less permeability in command and
she she didn't balance and won the final
year so we can't really rely on the
match prediction this is when the stats
say it will be different over the ball I
did I believe
yeah and I think that Alexandra said
that maybe this is one of the weaker
self ana that she doesn't play so much
only in chess and she doesn't work so
much on chess as she has family to keep
and Aleksandra plays a lot of work
recently she started to play a little
online chess and she is actually also
preparing for the candidates which is my
beginning in just a few days that's her
main focus the women's candidates
lamenting Kazan but I'm sure that she
will do everything she can shoot to a
non-student next round and as you
mentioned she since she has started her
own twitch channel and plays even more
online that should be an advantage she's
very familiar with the chancel complex
one and on the other hand we are not
sure whether she had the time to
practice at least for the match it's not
in general during the year though she
does wear a chest on t-shirt she does
and she has a very nice little note
there it says happy birthday to her
student
that's very nice I would love to have
such teacher me too he's gonna be
playing in front of a crowd of a couple
of thousand viewers and she has a
birthday greeting for her student be
sure about that and we will and both of
them I think
Alexandra O has a daughter also and both
of them are mothers though Alexandra did
a lot of things she worked as a model we
know her as chespin and she actually
played in a movie yeah I didn't know the
movie now we looked at Alexander's
career you know about a chess career I
didn't know that she played a role in
that Russian movie yeah and it was
pretty successful movie she played a
role there and the movie I think if we
translated in english it's called bless
the woman and it is pretty famous from
2003 and the movie afterwards won some
words so yeah I would like to ask her
how it is to play the movie I was always
interested in that
we lost for sure especially she wins
behind
it depends but I stink
first of all we will see three hours of
milling chests three hours cleaning of
hours the entire show at the very end of
the show we have introduced to the
anywhere but the game has just begun
first game of the second match of the
women's pictures champion and chest
Queen starts the game with 93g 3b 3b on
keto I think it is the bishops usually
she is playing before but because of
online chess and a lot of bleeds
tournament she explained she plays
everything when I was looking at her
games she she has like all sorts of
first moves and this is no exception
that and she tries to start with night
of three g3 I think we will see a lot of
different openings and so far it's a
very normal position right Knight of 3
b3 b4 c4 usually I like it very much
when there are too few petals and then D
for c4 and not deep freeze e4 what do
you think do you like when white plays
d4 or you prefer more deep green C 492
and playing on these a 1hh diagonal I
like what is Catalan type of setup and
the ponies on d4 and with these three
those are mainly the English opening
variation this because referring to I
think this usually is the slight
advantage for white because of the
pressure in the center and radicals
first or mark has already developed both
of her ambitions my plan will need to
take time to develop this da fish of the
series up is a problem facing these
openings right and this after she takes
d4 Knight takes d4 I think we've seen it
in the first match of Elena de Leon Ian
and Toby Milano as well they think here
is that after DJ C or B THC poor white
actually wants to take the receiver all
these people right now it would
be that impossible because c69 would be
hanging but after let's say 94 24 which
happened if black wants to take D takes
c4 I think white doesn't take wind
support but instead like either will go
Queen the age or would take B takes c4
because these actually this pawn would
turn o the Queen seaboard Queen but it
was also an interesting like we
mentioned that she had the option of
taking on the edge and then we
distinguish she may have been afraid
that that one can become a target so she
took on C with the Queen yeah of course
there are pros and cons of B take C or B
file is open and there is a lot of
pressure on b7 but after Queen support I
also like it
b5 what happened is pretty interesting
because that's a very smart way how to
unclean yourself and right away play for
equality because if Anna didn't play b5
rook a7 then it would be very difficult
for her to untie and what's to do with
this mission always the problem in this
position is that lights for a bishop is
kind of a bad piece it is and she has
managed this very important maneuver
this topic has described to at least
developed at you now there are still a
few issues to solve in blacks position
the bishop on d7 is not a place and the
Queen still has to find the best place
Queen B a to try to trade Queens I think
it's smart because this queen is
obviously more active than the black
Queen which will normally mean that much
trying to keep the Queen on the board
right Queen B 8 I like very much and
after trading everything that surprised
me I thought she will try to keep the
Queen then probably rook c8 and maybe
there was not good Square for the Queen
and trading is very direct
trades everything and makes the use of
the C because II rooks CAS now can white
play we should be seven-week c1 Luke c1
Bishop C 1 a 5 does it bring something I
don't think so it looks pretty it looks
it wasn't me because the phone can be
pushed where there's some curious is
Alexander will achieve anything after
this no Lucy is on the board and the
trade which it takes an average of c6
still a slight pressure by white one
this shouldn't be much of a difficulty
to pol I agree with you it is slightly
better for a white just because she has
better placed bishops and he and Bishop
see success better peace than the bishop
on c8 but it shouldn't be a problem to
defend this as we know the endgame role
is to bring the King to the center
because the king is very very important
pieces and games don't do it in video
games but it end games you to bring your
King to the center as soon as possible
best words another way still tricky for
at least game I think and I think that
Alexandra will try everything to make
something out of this I agree with you
and she's also handing the time better
Alexander still has over three and a
half minutes and Anna's down to two
minutes so clearly the chest Queen is up
to speed this is the five plus one
portion Alexander said that her favorite
temperatures three plus ones right in
the next segment but five plus one is
also similar in a sense that it's a
bleach game with one second increment
Alexander huge experience with online
chess
so I think you'll see her going
confident with the online chess
experience she has and we shall see how
anna can respond to it in this game i
think she will hold that is doing fine
the defense
yeah i agree with you though anna
generally is taking her time in real
games as well when we were following
hurricanes at olympia it was always that
she would think think that she would get
into time trouble and then when you
think about oh that's where i'm getting
taught her that she becomes a beast
she is like calculating so nicely and
she's very very
in these type of positions when she has
slight slight slight add she is pushing
it all the time it she never agrees draw
and she will like torture you know
because I was coming to a team there and
I was like oh come on it's a draw that
draw that draw but she was playing she
was playing yeah and she won the game
and I was like okay play a role here and
she's not over three minutes so three
minutes versus one minute and I was
going down the clock I think Anna we
have seen her play classical chess
dominance to where she would get into
serious trouble so she is the kind of
player that likes to use her time think
for a while idle at the end of the game
you need to speed up it's just a one
second increment that's it one second
increments right it's just one second
and it does not really help it helps
only if you are queen up and you want to
mate and you are not flat but you cannot
use this one seconds to speak and we've
seen how many times actually a meaner
than the onion flag and what we have on
the board right now is also very
interesting game I think that Alexandra
made some progress because of the h5
phone and the King has to be on f7 all
the time
it has to go to the h6 bar but good
thing for black is that there is a pin
so Bishop on b7 is not such a bad piece
it has to defend the a6 pawn but still
the bishop from d3 cannot go anywhere
than staying on b1 h7 diarrhea yeah now
the King goes back to garden g7 splitter
so people described already it's not
easy to make a progress in this position
even though White has pressure more
space and more activity with her pieces
how do you actually do something there's
a constant attack over the e4 pawn and
this Bishop alone will not make an
americorps so uncomfortably this is a
jaw but she was still trying she has two
and a half minutes over 20 seconds well
said
left for the four-time US Champion not
an easy situation especially when
chicken moves like this car do you want
to trade but don't you want oh now
there's a b6 past one yeah I like it I
like that she said that she took
everything because there is no pressure
any more on h6 pawn and it can be tricky
for white actually so who is first he's
gonna Queen first a to f7 a 1 or B a
look there is a check because a1 b8 I
think is possible yes yeah and then take
the h6 cannot be taken the Queen that's
a nice tactic about is in this position
by the way I can start giving checks
although we'd only checks you don't
achieve much even the King Antoine and
game would still be a draw is why I'm
gonna do still trade please the answers
in each Passport yes it is and a lot of
moves happened so we have Queen e3
defending the h6 but now what black
ships try is just not to trade the
Queen's because King is way too far but
this can be tricky when you have 10
seconds only 10 seconds on the board and
white has home but I like how I like the
way Anna is depending this because after
King d8 he wants to bring your team as
closer as possible and then actually you
can trade you can trade Queen stock now
depending very well but only 7 seconds
left for Anna's a tusky will she save
this game well in real life she's very
quick but in real chess game you have 30
minutes 30 second increments here you
have only one second and I think that's
an independent this game really nicely
though we should say kudos to both
players because Alexandre she shows the
way how to
some progress and i'ma show there's a
very nice defensive skills job beautiful
technique with Queen I think we have
seven in the end because the key and
pollen give is a jewel that white King
cannot come out of the corner very
instructive technique my Ana's at one
speed saves them difficult position
Indian because of the time pressure yes
so much about the endgame by the
temperature and now Anna has the white
pieces I'm gonna flip the board Anna has
white pieces and we now see Vienna gonna
be the Anna place a lot of d4 recently
though she was claimed efore and c4 as
well but recently it is Anna who
switched to d4 but we can see here a lot
of different lines what happens here I
like it for whites generally this line
because I think that white is the one
who is fighting for the center for space
advantage and black has to still show
how to equalize the biggest problem for
white here can be the c1 bishop so we
have now somatic match we have problems
with the bishop but this is a very
typical way of getting don't Knight c3
can be a repetition here but after a 92
Bishop d6 Bishop d2 is of course
possible and after 94 Bishop II won and
will have to expand on the Queen side
let's see what will happen will we have
a three-fold repetition or will wanna go
for something more Bishop d3 which it
leaves you on the board and I just
wanted to mention then as usual we have
a daily question what should the chest
community be doing to grow woman's chest
around the world that is a great
question and they would like to know
your opinion about it make sure to use
that hash their speeches on social media
so that doesn't know about your opinion
and we will definitely take that into
account because that is something that's
especially close to our hearts because
yeah
is doing a lot to develop a bigger chest
community about women chest is done more
girls more women turkey yes as a sport
I'm really happy I'm really happy chest
bone is doing so much for women's chest
and this is the first online women's
speech Chess Championship there was none
it just didn't exist it with on man and
yeah I would say just more tournament
and as you mentioned this is the first
ever women's features championship
$20,000 on the line and the winner will
qualify to the overall speeches
championship they're also the husband of
some people and his gear you will be
competing so who do I want to play
against a nation too dangerous this is
one more time this second game and it's
a tongues given to my PC is g3 of the 9h
5 to prevent the night jump to f4 is a
logical move and now g6 so that black
can prepare f5 in the future and this
knife has another different option too
much as the f6 square yeah a lot of
things happen to the pawn structure is
changed the e4 defy usually he's in
White's favor because it closes the b7
Bishop and it's not so easy for black to
play c5 which is very much needed to
have a relief in the center but um I
think Black has her own play on the King
side as we usually see in the Kings
Indian attack we have like f5 coming
expore and so on with Luke th Mookie 8
while black might try something with c6
and details c6 Bishop c6 if this happens
then it would be great for black but
it's not so easy visually for is nice it
is I like this more than I normally you
would like to see a knight in the center
and the central square but this Bishop
is you
school as it puts pressure on the seats
midnight and also in case they need
protection money fight it's just
generally a useful move and each freeze
the see per square for the rest of the
pieces of the night is coming in already
yelping toward b3 yeah and p3 is a very
important square because uh white can of
course play for before but he has to
take she has to take care of 93
Bishop c2 I like very much it kind of
serves two things first I wanted to take
on d4 and I want to play before as well
though after Bishop c3b takes c3 Knight
gets for Boston c c5 there is no more
before and white can it keep this nine
out but what happened is that white made
her center way stronger because after
let's say c6 white can always play
Singapore and c6 would be ideal if white
would take on c6 with D takes c6 Bishop
c6 but if after c64 then BB phone would
be pretty pretty weak I like 85 a lot
because that's about we can be the queen
side and if this trade happens on v6vf
iPhone becomes a protected pospone
that's indeed a very good move because
a5 b5 see for inclusion is of course in
White's favor the white has to take care
of moves like rook b8 let's say if black
decides to play rook eb 8c j XB v a
takes d5 Queen b5 that there are moves
like 55 and so on maybe we can show it
with arrows like Ricky b8 and C takes B
585 Queen b5 and Bishop d5 tactics yeah
I can surely spectacle not in this some
people talk about there's a discovered
attack over the Queen yeah and I don't
know
who is playing for once but a lot of
things happened and it is now Alexandra
who has to be a bit careful because so
far I liked very much how Anna play she
doesn't want a course to give up this
pond so easily so she takes we take see
poor Queen takes t4
you
and miss easier really important the c5
Knight has lost the output there is no
porn protecting it from people nor
demons so this is going to be a
difficult position for X under also if
you look at the g7 9 that's not gonna
have the c59 to see a picture three
minor piece back to that are not
coordinating but yes I agree with you
completely
nighttime g7 is not doing anything and
it's very important that white has to
lay on B and C fun
what should black do how can we create
some sort of counter-attack because
after bishops d8 it is clear that black
wants to play Bishop g4 and then humpy
would be pretty annoying especially when
he gives away yeah that's a smart move
to prevent the pin that so people talked
about bishop different and still calm
but as we would have been an option for
white and change the patient okay so
Alexander goes my left eye which i think
is very much in her style she will not
just wait for the exposition to be worse
and worse she was an aggressive
attacking counter chance even if your
position is worse she tries to create
something they should be bring very
strong very nice move just kicking this
night out now look at the position is
like Bishop on c8 9 27 policies happenes
we everything is weak and white has
great night on d2 if F E is always in
white paper that's 90 Boris would be
there f4 I think is the one of the ways
Alexander should think about but of
course for example now if I play F for G
takes a poor oh there is Bishop c5 move
I think because it seems like Bishop
doesn't have any
squares but after asked for white crew
to play Bishop c5 and these pieces not
hanging because our Centurion quit
because of this pin yeah
so that is why f4 was not quite and
after Bishop a4 rook d8 Queen sees these
such a nice technique I really really
like it what do I happen after Bishop cc
though I'm still wondering because the
rugby lights will be eight right so and
instead when Felicia's think the idea is
similar maybe she wants to take with
deep on when maybe she has both options
both are camping - it takes c6 and let's
see what happens after you'll be eight
or he takes c6 and the night has barely
any goose breast yes this is going to be
a difficult position for Alexandra to
defend just me still has more time so
time management is definitely what
Alexander have been doing brave us so
far she doesn't take on Cystic one place
instead root to be a and now after a
couple of my moose is speeding up 19
seconds left for Anna we don't have much
time to go into details in the
variations oh my god yeah I really like
a whites position just only problem here
is that white has 17 seconds but the
position was completely we need to me
because there are so many ideas so many
things like 96 what do you think 90
states
he takes P six eighty x p6 and oh my god
stop those pawns I agree with you that
was something that as a trade booth it
was have been captured but this mine
together with the spin on the background
that's the most annoying black cannot
move the bishop of a fancy she plays
rook e8 to free the bishop but still
this is going to be very difficult for
Alexandra there's this post there's this
weakness on a6 and if you lose days
exploring the a5 or will win Danny and
the first one yeah I think that I missed
a chance to win the game directly now
it's not so easy anymore
I think Knight b6 could have been go
away oh she said yeah winning the bishop
suddenly from a better game and as a
toastie blunders a piece and she also
lost on time but this was about the
discover let's just quickly show that
she didn't realize about the Bishop e5
95 is this man winning a piece and again
I assume because new takes the lead yeah
Alex
takes the lead we've a big blunder but
when you have 10 seconds on clock yeah
you can miss it you can forget that
Bishop is on a 4 it happened and I will
have to forget the bind immediately the
next game has just started there's no
time to recover they need to recover
right here playing the next game for one
and a half hours they will be playing
this first segment that's 5 minutes plus
1 second increment yeah and this is a
one-point lead then we have actually
seen in the prediction was a convoy
match segment yeah for Alexandra still
waiting to go yeah and Alexandra chooses
the English opening but again once again
with both G 3 and B 3 just the
difference what you did in the first
game is that the night is not an f3 but
it's now 92 93 system I like it for
white because when you play against g3
be free and the way black played c5 is
very difficult you want to double the
pawns on the C file and then after D
takes d5 D takes e5 that's what happens
in the game 25 does white have some kind
of tricky jumps let's say Queenie 594 we
have to be careful not to blunder the
bishop and the queen goes away from g7
maybe nice be safe or we can simply have
a pressure on c5 for example Queenie 7
room c1 or fish of a3 that looks very
very tricky I'm leaving you and as
usually we'll talk about the players in
general we have mentioned already that
we have here to the top female players
in the world is the four-time US
Champion
and as a constant facing former virgin
be arguments for champion accent
accosting she was the world champion
among senior players from 2008 to 2010
she has won basically everything is
possible to win including Olympic gold
medals with the team of Russia every
single time they play European team
champions a relative championship chess
olympiad their team of Russia Angela
means and Alex and I settle for the most
of these events yeah Alexander sometimes
is first part of that because Russian
team is so strong that you have lots of
lots of players who are above 2500 and
about 2500 for women is like really
great you get to be grandmaster man's
Grandmaster title and sometimes she
plays like she's world champion she's
really chess Queen and sometimes she
plays on board three supply support for
sometimes for one it depends on the
period she won a lot of gold medals also
on board gold medals Olympic European
world team as well as Anna they both
actually
Anna is Ukrainian but she moved to us
when she was pretty pretty young and
then she got married
and now she's living in Germany with her
husband they both have chess player just
when children lost their husbands yes
[Music]
yeah it's it's very interesting just
players life you feel like you're born
in it you friendship was living in you
as she was representing Ukraine for a
long time she even won some team medals
and she moved to USA she warned us
championship women's championship four
times and that's very very impressive
because it's always very strong the
women's championship
and now she represents us which leaves
in Germany because just when I think is
a lot of fun it is and also as we
mentioned the team results of Alexandra
Anna has to compete in as you mentioned
for the team of the United States for
the last couple of additions on the
chess Olympians over to deductions when
I'm trying to end of the numbers the
team of you as a limousine has born
silver a bronze medal and an unheard war
she won a gold medal those players are
really good team players Beyonce yeah
and both of them and it's important to
be not only individual player but also
good in team because sometimes it's not
only about you and it's not only about
your results you sometimes team result
is depended on you and that's a lot of a
lot of pressure
speaking of team results and such I
managed to click on the room and this is
in position apologies I was not up to
date in my born after Queen c4 check
this in T current position where the
time situation is roughly balanced it's
good news for any have mesh to speed up
but the position let's see Quincy for
check where shall the black King go is
not easy there's 96 coming in and maybe
six is this already
game over yeah doesn't look good because
we're the king should go actually Queen
King be 726 King up six Queenie six pink
to g7 and I played the 96 King he ate is
the only way but first Queen g8 is very
smart and then Queen he yeah it loses
the pitcher and nice a 224 Alex and
after once again winning the bishop wins
the piece that's the bishop one more
time 2 point 3 4 LX and across the new
after three games so Anna will need to
bounce back in this game where she has
the white pieces yeah though there's a
lot of time a lot of games though so far
alexandra is playing strong and
on those little tactics but on Amit's
warmup
so we never know what will happen in the
match so part of us so good for
Alexandra let's you wanna play the game
d4 Knight of 6 and we have the Queen's
Indian and I like to play games Queen's
Indian more with g3 e3o also is a very
big wine and same position here with C
takes d4 Knight takes d4 after DC for
now this is the moment where you don't
want to take with the b-pawn because b6
and Bishop d7 is already on board and we
have Bishop on d3 and not on h1 aah
diagonal so B takes e4 what I was
talking about in the first game doesn't
really make sense I know we can just
show it also there's trouble on the
violence of the other questions that mr.
Bishop is hanging so you don't want to
be about the t49 for free that would
lose a piece yeah I think 9 c4 is very
natural but also Bishop c4 comes to mind
and what happens Bishop c4 I mean I see
six and now three on sacred soil so far
bringing the Queen to e2 to connect the
roots they potentially are here on D 1
and C 1 on the next moves that's a very
real tournament strategy when you're
losing two games in a row you just want
to stop the bleeding and you want to
play solid if it's a draw it's a draw
it's ok so I think it's very smart with
Anna he's doing now she doesn't take a
lot of risks just she shouldn't blunder
she shouldn't run there I like this
green one over by Alexandra the queen
will most likely end up on the long
diagonal Queen Bishop battery put some
pressure on the long diagonal and
commentaries as well yeah it is indeed
nice
now after between b7 I think white can
leave the 19 X 3 so we can
while it's a root D 1 because 95 is not
any way possible cheated ponies hanging
but I don't think it would be nice for
black to take on app 3 because after G
takes at 3 and really like that point
would have to bishops open G file and it
doesn't really matter that's like breeze
once palm structure I really knew that
my shouldn't be afraid of Bishop mixed
up we end up in the phones
therefore else and it doesn't even mind
whether she wants to take or not it will
be in the air it's good to have this
Queen Bishop better because of the
pressure of the GT point but simply she
wants to trade rooks on the D file and
equalize because overall this is a game
and black piece is two point lead in the
match she doesn't need to force issues
in this game yeah only thing that
bothers me or why it is that black can
easily keep the bishop out so b5 is
always kind of in the air so to me eight
more counts as a logical move but I
don't want to give up the very important
be for square because not only Bishop
can get there but after 9594 might be
annoyed this is a nice solution against
b5 Bishop h6 and just to get rid of this
Queen on B file and not to worry about
b5 anymore it's been a smart move you
make sure that there we know that trying
problems takes away the cheapest plan as
well
multi-purpose move but still the trades
found on the define the question will be
whether one can put up some fight here
to build on the tension it's a slight
edge but Anna would need to bounce back
and try to win this game yeah it is
difficult with this position it is
really difficult because there is
nothing wrong with blacks position and I
I can feel the pressure that you really
want to win it but position should allow
right yes this will most likely lead to
a draw but we have seen big mistakes
head the first game she lost she was
pressing trying to win there and then it
was a one room longer than even Julie
Kate the point Alexandra in this chest
anything can happen and I'm down to two
and a half minutes and once again ahead
in time they can repeat was here and you
know they even have already made it
visual support we need for efficiently
25 that was a very objective drool yeah
he's still another left and our left
from the match and I has abandoned her
seat for a moment that she and she came
a real quick of course they can do
whatever they like in their time no one
stops the clock you want to go to the
bathroom your time will be running she
will need to be very quick but I see her
two kids are at home maybe that she
needed to help them well I understand
that very much now work number four is
busy with my little one story how we
started today shall we were about to go
alive today and then the road number
four aka Grandmaster a nice giri just
knock on the door quietly looked in and
we have started already or she or he
could still get some help from his wife
because apparently there was an issue
guess what was the reason yeah to change
the diaper just but I love this because
I just think like you know I'm busy
I'm just going live in like two minutes
[Music]
and each the experience the baby this is
it should be right now because you are
accustomed the top man of the day that
is between accent accustomed and and
SFSP both of the harm others and
professional chess player yeah I was
smelling Ganesha actually that he should
hurry up from what kind of Grand Prix in
Moscow the knockout system it was very
good for me the knockout systems I was
like okay hurry up I have chest from
life so you have to babysit with Daddy
yes
one also let's remind everybody that we
will choose one more time the moment of
the day which is the best play please
make sure that whenever you see a moment
in the show a very exciting moment of
the game or something funny interesting
that happened during the broadcast clip
it and send it to us I think by clipping
it probably will see anybody well if you
tweet it even better
use the hashtag speeches to answer the
question of the day and also to send us
your clips because we will choose the
best clip for the moment of the match
that will be sure right before the poet
portion yeah and actually it's very
important that you share ideas with us
because chest pom is doing everything we
take into consideration what do you
think what viewers wants to see how can
we grow woman's chest though please do
that and now back to the game that was
actually first one first
efore by Alexandre it was batcher the
line I wish we had Patrick with the
night of sixes not very the most popular
let's say so but as I've seen on I
explained a lot of Patrick's recently
and she with likes to go back with night
I also used to play Patrick for Belize I
preferred
Oliver glace because of her voice you
know I keep oil to mine neither
and it's pretty interesting it looks
like that you don't have space and you
have like you have limited squares where
to put your I were to put your pieces
but what you have to remember if you
want to pay Patrick play Patrick is the
e-file efile is very important because
the position is pretty close all five
girls on efile and whoever has it either
has the initiative or equalizes I agree
with you fool another not had to come
back from a fire since it lost the
support of the bishop because of this 94
move and black has the possibility of it
obtain 1gb
or on day two right and after night g3 I
think best is I would still take it on
g3 because after FG at least every
square could be slightly weak but what
white gets three is that the night on g6
looks pretty silly now it is of the H
breath or a squares right it cannot
color anywhere
therefore any thinking whether to take
on g3 or take on d2 it's an important
moment
it makes them that she's using more time
and if you guys haven't seen it before
she is varying a chance that whole
t-shirt and a note on the t-shirt that
is for her student and the student of
Ana has his or her dress they need to
ask more imagined and after the match is
over but it's a very nice gesture from
Ana it is elite the student exactly and
it's really nice I really I would really
love to have such bold brilliant
I'm honest yeah she didn't did neither
on GC no Nandi to but they're friendly
the nice defined that was the third
option and that opens up the day on
artificial to so she can activate the
application later yeah I like d5 because
if now white takes 94 D takes e4 that
would be very annoying for white because
then as pi we can play and we can
strengthen the center central pawns
Queen e1 is very logical
now it forces actually glad to take
decision does she really wants to have
tonight an important play at 5 or trade
everything as it happens in the game
Bishop d6 this looks very nice instance
that because of d5 like one a lot of
temples with Bishop d6 and rook e8 very
fast and probably this will be also a
solid draw I think it is having to
original as you mentioned after the
multiple trades this position is rather
simple and there's no
to play for the chess queen is aiming to
create some tension I'd like this gene
for Bishop at five idea because
efficient except except the Nile is
struggling you will need to come back to
for instance key seven this is what we
are going to see so there's some space
advantage and some pressure and the King
said for Alexandra who is two points off
in the match
yeah and actually when she was asked
like how she would prepare when I would
Center was asked in the
pre-matching knew how she would prepare
for the match what would be most
difficult she said that just sitting
there in front of computer and playing
for three hours can be challenging
because it's a very long match and can
play a lot of games but just to be there
online for three hours and it it is very
challenging and I agree with her that's
why probably they need snacks right
anyways we've seen Alexandra having some
cookies and I'm interested when is the
moment when she's gonna use the cookies
when she needs the energy so her she's
she's just not taking anything and she's
very focused on the game and moves but
I'm really looking forward to see the
moment when she gets fired do I see the
chocolate in was in the chip welcome
everybody just joining us on chest TV
and on twitch obviously we are
monitoring the chat but we can't really
type in the chat I have sometimes tried
to spend more time I'm gonna prove on
there by using my very own emotes
clogging my channel but yes we are
monitoring the chat so make sure to talk
to us on chest TV and on which let us
know about your opinion about this net
who are you rooting for and also please
remember them
question of the day and the clips that
we are waiting for yeah please do and we
have pretty equal end game there is
probably not much to talk about because
everything is closed and Alexandra is
trying to get
some traits to create some weaknesses
and that's a very smart way but I think
I will help hold it pretty easily just
the thing is that we see that Alexandra
he has a great time management while
unhappy is having always some seconds on
the clock
70 seconds left for the four times
champion this is problematic in the
sense that once again she's Valentine
it's a different ball and game but a
center has the pressure and two and a
half minutes let it not be five and she
will have to face the questions whether
there's a breakthrough and the night is
a tricky piece yeah now I don't like
what happens because a night before was
easily allowed and now King comes to
deport I was even going to say that
there were some ideas with 95 f8c party
takes apart but that's even better
what happened for white here this looks
really really badly
- oh my Anna is in serious buying
pressure and now this is going to be
still difficult with the weakness on the
fact she has managed to prevent him
before so if I was a really smart move
but with three seconds on the clock
rush it's two minutes this isn't looking
good for Anna this is not but position
God's simplified now after knight c6
there is 95 and we shouldn't forget that
but it also has a weak bond and G for
any black manages to take that home she
will create her sound oppressor so I
think alexandra has to be a bit careful
as well it's not only that you're
looking at your opponent's clock which
happens is a pretty usual mistake it
happens several times to me that a while
opponent has wide open it is in time
trouble you're trying to play as fast as
possible and that's a big mistake when
you have time you have to use it because
when your alternate is in time travel
she's more focused she sees the tactics
better I think better than
you Anna has made a movie with one
second left in the heart and they are
repeating news though so if this is
gonna be the third time that King be 493
is play that it is a true and Alexandra
go straight Wow one second left on the
clock when an event for this variation
it is an escape from a difficult
situation in terms of the time situation
at least yeah it isn't next game we have
nimzo-indian so we see a lot of
different openings it's we don't have
cinematic match today as we had in the
first match of the million haha it was
really impressive that we have team of
two bishops but we've seen here several
openings and what's still very thematic
in these matches that we see a lot of pn
Kato's rights like b6 Queen's Indian or
g3 Alexandra and Bulls I think Anna
they'd like to put their Bishop on db2
like sometimes people will be free
Bishop Beatson happens a lot of times
it's true the fee and control visually
I've seen even the non-indian get though
with jeans with Bishop to peace with
Bishop b2 those have been some of the
themes all the day and two times we have
seen a piece blunder unfortunate for
Ana's a toss key that Yankees in two of
the teams that weren't excited in terms
of the opening they have been switching
I'm still waiting for the French defense
I thought there would be many French
difference Canada is the French and I
like center often was for one in four
but so far we have not seen coming if
you want to follow alexandra by the way
she of course has her own twitch channel
screams often on chance calm hover
your mouse over the screen if you are
watching from a PC then you will be able
to follow her channel I believe my
channel is also there totally on my
channel click on Alex and just channel
that's my request thank you yeah right
and actually as we mentioned Alexandra's
point soon in candidates tournament
which starts like at 29th so today's 26
in three days and
another psychological moment is that she
has to be careful not to show what she
prepared for the candidates tournament
because if she plays everything that she
prepared for the candidates of course
opponents are watching and of course
they are following this match and just
looking for what openings is Aleksandra
using so she has a bit of difficulties I
think that is why we don't receive more
of offbeat lines with g3 fianchetto b3
Bishop b2 rather than main lines we eat
or deepen c4
I agree with you this since an excellent
dimension and a pre matched that we had
with her that her main focus obviously
is the candidates tournament is starting
in just a few days on the 29th of May in
Kazan the Aged player field for the
first time is a women's candidates
tournament for the World Chess
Championship and that's of course one of
the most important events for a female
player in order to become well champion
she was already the world champion
between 2008 and 2010 but that doesn't
mean she doesn't wanna repeat of course
she is very competitive and she has
ambitious to come back to get back her
crown she is doing a lot of things for
that and actually in our field we have a
lot of players from on candidates
tournament we will have soon Valentina
who Nina's match who is also the
participant of the candidates tournament
so we we are doing really great things
like having a speech Chess Championship
having pulled this and interest on all
this great for years and it's just great
to see that they complete each other in
these events some of the events to the
court and as for the witness features
championship this is the second match
remember that this is the first and a
chest of organizing the penis which is
campus it can be thousand dollars on the
line and
will qualify to the overall speeches
championship that's gonna be this summer
the winner will move on to the next
round so as you know this is the second
match and who has two more matches to
see who are the players that will make
it winter funds yeah and what we have on
the board it looks slightly Pleasant or
white look at this beautiful B file we
just need to be done and it will be
completely full but I like White's
position because the b2 bishop I think
it's better place to know what white
should be careful will ease the be for
fun and Alexander is using it very
nicely hey Bishop e7 and the knight on
c6 they are both now attacking the be
for fun and how to defend it I don't
really see a good way to defend it for
Bishop III even video against Kluber and
the bishop on his way is questionable
yeah also roommate for can be an option
for black to put more pressure on be for
fun and I really really just like it
maybe we should just ignore it and play
something like 9 th9 th why we can apply
because knight eh brother and I would
just blunder I hope pieces there is no
g7 we just have a maze after 96 allowing
9 we completely forgot that nicely
things even though they were focus is
gonna be for fun so apologies but they
were so impressed with disappointed we
forgot that the bishop it still has a
square if you move the bishop the c6
Knight is unprotected tactics here and
this will mean that black have to give
up the minor piece on d5 and she will
give up a second minor piece and Sivan
so it's gonna be the fight of a route
versus two minor pieces yeah though we
know that two minor pieces in most cases
our best and also I think that after 98
Queen d2 night c1 there is a there is an
intermediate move d6 instead of taking
root c1 in the law in 95 yeah Quinn
every happen so I wanted to show that
you don't want to move it to be sure
because that will allow the capture with
an attack you want to move it to square
yeah that doesn't run and takes p1 with
the attack over the pin and then so
because idea will work so one more time
is equal capture 92 and the Queen went
over to f3 90s it won't be sick this is
exactly what so people was talking about
intermediate move very important certain
indeed takes it seven and now I expect
on c1 yeah I like it for white because
I'll also have a very strong d6 fund
that's the main point of the position
and two minor pieces so it looks good
for Ana mainly this is the game where
she can really come back maybe this is
the one what do you think I think so to
the least expose one is extremely strong
my species are very active she will of
course still need to find the most
precise way to play how to put even more
pressure on Alexandra and use for a time
whether it's 54 seconds left or enough
we have seen her struggle in most of the
games in terms of time management and
his trade on d5 is this something that I
wanted that much yeah maybe if we look
at Alexandra ball if we look at her
she's very expressive also with her
emotions and when she doesn't like
something I noticed from real games and
real tournaments because I've seen her a
lot of times she kind of takes a deep
breath and she's like I think it counts
very much to take off the pressure I was
always told when the when I was
preparing for tournaments and when I was
keep that if you don't want to
you have pressure and you're just just
look around take three seconds before
they very important decision and take a
deep breath and make a move I think
that's a very good tips I use breathing
techniques there are to cool yourself
down because you don't wanna make a
quick decision with a nervous anxious or
upset state of mind in terms of the
position it has one already one form it
is 97 check it was very nicely played
you don't want to take this night
because that will take a monster and
materials have been low
that's why Alexandra had to give up the
pawn on d5 and when we see in the
current position is that white has two
minor pieces against aru normally Erica
and the pawn equals two minor pieces yes
we +3 the too many pieces find us one
who can the pawn here as if in this
position white has a phone app that will
be the material balance right and I
always prefer to have two minor pieces
though one thing that one should
remember is that it's a tricky in end
games when you can allow to have two
minor pieces for Luke and maybe two or
three pawns and this is a middle game
where you might have attack it's very
dangerous to have two to play against
two minor pieces you should not allow it
in the endgame because usually end game
is very tricky because rooks are somehow
stronger than two minor pieces if of
course black has enough pause what
happened here is that there was a trade
and another con was gun but now two
pieces just just for the records we have
to remind our results that you cannot
trade everything and be up with two
knights because that's a drop believe
and now after winning one it is still
some work to do because of us up a
commission if you only have one night at
the end or if
two nights tonight comes win the case so
it's a full piece off for another town
SCADA system so far the biggest
advantage that she has had during the
games of this match yeah but she still
has to work a ratio with 18 seconds left
on the car yeah and the important here
is not to trade all pants because then
it's nearly impossible to win the game
though I did it on a did win the game in
Olympia with rook and my vs. route I
don't take it very very bad at World
Championship but normally normally black
doesn't lose right but this looks
completely winning because there are
pawns on the board and once the pawns
advance there is no way black can defend
it now for example g7 is lost
yes this was a very nice maneuver
putting pressure on the seventh rank and
then bring in the night after winning
the g7 pawn this position is completely
winning and therefore X under resigns
because it does matter and if you have
more time for the Jester that gives
smart strategy by Chesley yes resigning
was smart that's that's a very unique
resigning this is a very special format
and as Foreman is that they have half an
hour left from the segment that is five
million plus one second s time poncho
and I center has a one-point lead now
but she wants to keep that lead and
increase that lead so she needs to play
more and more and more nice where she is
not a piece down right and that is
actually a lot of confidence boost to
the one who is down on score because
it's like okay you want who wants to
won't win one more and then there is a
lot of pressure to the one who is
actually meeting and we have counts but
we have constants on the board I really
like it I play this line though I'm not
hustling
so fast I usually play in Queen City
first and then I decide what to do with
the game maybe I want to castle long
side
was the miner was using and then G or H
4 or this is the way also another way to
deal with lease line with 95 and at 4
and as far as I know when wise achieves
nights of 5 and 4 then white has slight
advantage
I like it a lot of cousins night it's
very on 25 the bishop on e6 put into
oppression the King sign and a file is
pushed which will weaken the black King
said you don't really want to see this
kind of posters you're in front of your
king
no yeah you don't want to see an after
f5 9:00 to 5:00 is of course possibility
with a maybe exchange sacrifice is
possible 9:00 to 5:00 Bishop a5 Bishop
at 5:00 Ruka 5 and G takes of 5 Queen f5
there's a lot of the things going on
because King is very weak and there is
direct threat of mates now with 25 mg 7
and as file is open my 25 is a beast so
after f5 I think honest should not touch
the theme ponent m5 I agree with you
that this exchange sacrifice is very
interesting on that but of course the
players are allowed to stand up we have
already mentioned is that they can
always go to the bathroom we have a
glass of water from the kitchen or have
their kids it will divorce our mothers
and so as long as the time is running
they cannot stop of course the time
there's no such thing as ok but they can
do whatever they wish at their time they
do but be positioning so times that I
think both players will be splitting
very nicely in their chairs focusing on
their screens now for example night at 7
can be can be a problem couldn't be
night of seven pink of 7 F takes G seis
and then we also take the h7 pawn I
think it is very tempting I really will
not have time to analyze it much because
f6 is only one in H states g6 giving on
the X
won't happen anyway that means that Ana
was very scared of something in this
position a test extreme same as a bishop
g6 proficient in sex anyway would happen
maybe
yeah I'm struggling to understand what
would happen because if there is any
sacrifice on g6 them it would anyway
Hamlin with iPhone or H bar um I don't
know me as well we are trying to move
understand here is by an expelled the
need to take with the age born give up
the x7 on allowing this capture and the
attack over her Queen
if f66 instead would have been plain it
still looks bad for that we are not
saying that we like blacks position
right it's probably already very
problematic there can be potential
sacrifice on g6 97 is anyway an option
or dr7
but we do not know the exact reason
since this isn't anymore the key in
position text and 9th except 7 and I
will come back to the world and make a
move there aren't many squares would
Queen yeah I think I think that's a
family life because Ana has two kids and
we've see that while playing leads
online on ice leaving the board and
already maybe she thinks that she
doesn't have nice position so she can
get up and take like 30 seconds to do
what she has to do she has brought a
hoodie with herself before she was
sporting the chest from a t-shirt and a
greeting for a student of hers it's the
birthday of a student of Ana that was
the note on her t-shirt but we see that
it's a bit chilly in Germany and now
she's wearing a st. Louis hoodie
yeah we also need one yeah we have kind
of same weather conditions but the
matches so it's melting that are not
cold in the position it's heating up but
it's heating up in the very one way for
MSF
two paws down and now the exchange is
falling as bad and wish I was jumping on
the Queen
game over and Aleksandra is loving she
just just burst in love man indeed
I wonder what exactly this she's so
because normally just because she has
made a winning move she wouldn't start
celebrating it must be something else
yeah and she she she has a big smile on
her face can you imagine like husband is
in front of her and he's just cheering
her like who knows both of these players
we mentioned already have chess player
husbands grandmasters yeah I'm not on
your team she was loving and you can
have some funny ones you're not related
to chess I just want to give a quick
shout that chance gremlin and also I see
another lady that goes Ethel Pepe I have
missed this any no donations apologies I
don't have another tab to look at the
notifications but we do appreciate each
and every support the other is big
donation subscriptions or simply the
fact that you are here with us sharing
this moment witnessing an epic match
between the former women's world
champion accent Acosta you and a fourth
are US Champion and toasty this is just
the beginning of the match it is it is
because we still have 26 minutes left or
five plus one portion and then we will
have three plus one for another 60
minutes and half an hour for bullets
that should be very very exciting I
think that I won't be able to give up
well Keith should really be late yeah be
fine what do you think of this most of
people be high that's very impressive
because they should be 5 is 20 but after
would be 8 we would open the B file and
Queen b6 and
suddenly out of nowhere white king might
be in danger as well as let's play is
easier because she takes the initiative
on the Queen side and yeah afterwards it
might be on who should be thinking of
defense
that's why Hannah goes for 9g I mean is
that it's not Lisa Carson position and
both players will aim for the opponent's
king the king is the objective of the
game but in opposite side crossing it
happens immediately you go for a phone
storm your sacrifice piece it's porn
whatever you can you get your attack
going exactly that usually happens in
Sicilian positions very much so I'm very
much used to these opposite casting and
AH I'm the one who is who has the castle
and Queen King site I'm playing against
queenside castle
so these moves like b5 rook b8
before and so on is kind of very typical
for such positions only problem here for
black is that it's not so easy to open
with b4 as wine has c4 and then if
everything is blocked White has free
hand on a king side so instead she
pushes in the center that's not that
simple because it weakens the c5 bone
and also the D file White has both the
Queen and the look on the defiled c4 not
to get in this moon before the d5 point
is protected thanks to the 9 so it may
be just in time
blacks attack is way more advanced than
white of that we see that the white bone
will need to be pushed to squares just
to get in touch with the Jeep on yeah
and then well and that's actually where
we have to pay attention how nice the
[Music]
Aleksandra got some sort of attack on
the Queen side because d5 you would
think that okay where
what would the ship land but her plan
was very clear with d5 c4 and before
otherwise without d5 before wouldn't it
be possible because the c-4 bond would
be hanging so some clear play black has
on the Queen side but I still think that
it's
very dangerous because of this Bishop
one before which is protecting the
important see three squares in case of
be Texas Revolution exactly let me take
simply to trade the Queen so far Anna is
depending the reason and in the piece
that is defended and she can go on with
her King side attack yeah h5g for h6
though it would be also difficult for
her to create something because after h5
h6 is possibility for black to stop it
but that's kind of provocation because
if you play h5 h6 then White's attempt
to create some attack on the King side
would be easier because 9 h 3g 4g pi
would be already a big threat i redo
that the g4 not even though it's put in
question it's in the vein of the gene
prohibition see her and i will continue
once again she is using more time than
alexandra we have seen the time
management being better for the chess
queen she has been doing very well she
speeds are even in first positions yeah
now anna still has one in the five
minutes which is still better than
twenty second but she had to come up
with something and this is the critical
moment she has to make a serious
decision about the next couple moons not
just Devo animal that she will play
right now yeah and actually it's a very
interesting position like should you
ignore everything and just bill h5g for
right away or should you do some kind of
prophylactic
moves and more nerves like let's say
king game one comes to mind and any
other but she goes for g4 which I think
it's pretty logical
it is logical and she can decide to move
the night major it's a bit said if you
need to go to a speech I guess she's
amazing whether there will be a better
chance you wish you could just take your
bishop on e6 and push but for now it is
a move that takes away the f-4s bug from
the plant bishop in case yeah and stars
the phone stone we shall steal their
black can continue if this is paralyzed
because unfished the bishop taking on
city of indexes week
it has to come up with something else be
swings another option right and just to
remind our viewers it's nice to be a
programmer and three pounds we love free
stuff we do love it but the thing is in
this position is that if we take our f6
and after Bishop f6 Bishop f6 we take on
d5 even if we are not losing the c3 pawn
right away
it would be very difficult for white
then to defend the dark squares this
dark square bishop is defending
everything on Queen side so then you
don't have any danger and you shouldn't
do it like just for the sake of one
point you shouldn't do it even even
though the information leads you don't
think that's position that's what so
people saying if it was once again well
I was gonna say balloon once again
Western yeah it's it would be think we
just by principle you don't really want
to give up this strong bishop on c4
which is attacking and defending at the
same time yeah for one isolated pawn and
I didn't stand up it's it's a bad one I
was gonna say backward upon it really is
off the board the current position if
the game is this long after Queen d2
unless you're not mating on h7 you
shouldn't take on six don't do that yes
so Alexander is actually leading with
two points right now so this game is
pretty decisive it is twenty minutes
left on this segment and I will need to
make a comeback there's a tree to c3
ambition before threatening Bishop takes
c3 remember there's a pin on the B files
and contact on c3 with the Queen right
and I actually in chance that most of
you like black Flex position here though
I this has been another blunder by Anna
she already has suffered a defeat a
piece Brandon because of a discovered
attack
is another one that will show very
quickly she took on g6 forgetting about
the Queen side and the Queen on d2
hanging this was game over if King c1
would be one check would have won the
Queen anyway another point for accent a
three point lead
yeah another point and she has three
point lead that was not expected that
much on Sodor from the predictions that
we've announced it was just one points
lead in the five-minute segment indeed a
smarter chess prediction stats for this
match was showing advantage for
Alexander but the fight was non portion
is where we predicted that Anna would be
doing very good and it would be just one
point difference between two yeah then
we have to say that alexandra is the
favorite with the rating points as well
and she she has played a lot of beats in
her life and I think it's very important
that alexandra has a lot of chest though
we know now at this moment in her life
because she is preparing for the
candidates tournament
indeed accent doesn't professional just
so is Anna but this is a different stage
of their career where Alexander is
playing some of the heat off event and
for death she has do you know how many
hours put in every serious chess
preparation plus she streams and she
plays online
very often by Anna doesn't play that
much this is of course an advantage when
you face an online competition that you
have way more experience playing on
chance at home yeah and it's a very
usual question asked to me like what do
you think is the ideal amount of time
you should put in chess if you wants to
become a grandmaster and I don't know I
don't have response for that I think
that is very individual and like who can
do what because
chess is not only that he study books
and some tactics by online
so on but it's also pretty you have to
be physically beats and I am really
interesting how these girls
professionals are taking what kind of
amount of time are they putting in chest
because it's saying that both of them
are very competitive they are
professional chess players so they have
to work very hard I know that Alexandra
is paying a lot of attention to sports
she was jogging even during turns you
will see her coming back to the hotel on
stage the event in German :
yeah you will see always during the
tournaments that she takes morning jobs
and she's like very sportive she's very
much in shape and I think when you have
two or more kids that's also some sort
of Jeana they have two kids mr. mustard
Friedman and as husband we mentioned
that both Alexandra and and I have
chance families I don't know who else
similar situations that we may know more
about how is it how is your chest how
much it does not have I don't know in
advantage husband well it's definitely
he's because whenever I I play something
can you tell me what's going on here
until you tell me what's going on there
but I think it's also advantage for them
for professional chess players because
we understand why they are sitting in
front of computers for $1 why they are
always like moving the wooden pieces and
I think it's very nice to understand
what your another half is up to indeed I
agree with you that's why we see many
more than professional chess players
getting married to other chess player
just controls
yes just I'm still waiting for the World
Championship watches but let's get back
to this position after 93 it's quite
solid it's why we were not focusing on
it much the position is balanced
we divide these it's heading for the F I
spent with her night the other man can
jump to effects of some slight pressure
is that accent is building up see fire
and I'm in this situation I think she
does worships you she needs to spice up
the position even if it's quite an equal
dollar position right in fact it's an
isolated Pumbaa allows an attack over
the diagonal for sure now it's very
difficult to say exactly when is the
time to really go all in because we
still have three plus one segments ahead
and bullet match ahead so is each the
moment where you have to go all in
because you're down three points or you
can play normal solid chest and then see
what happens and how it goes good
question after Bishop b5 and clean up
fire this is becoming more and more
complicated for a negative pressure oven
defy poll and she accepted to have the
isolated yeah and the screen around the
kingside amber will be happy about it
also the Knights are too close yeah I
agree with you completely the only thing
that I like for black is the moon Bishop
c4 and that's very nice to get rid of
the isolated pawn on d5 but we really
see that after Queen c2 it's not so easy
to get rid of the isolated pawn and as a
rule we know that when you have isolated
pawn you shouldn't try to trade pieces
true this will Bishop takes it what it
takes it would allow their own structure
of black becoming someone better that
will be nice at that one but the capture
and here and so people sell alone it's
not something that luck is interested in
it now the knight on d4 is very well
pleased that's how you should place your
minor pieces and you're playing it can't
be isolated for the d4 pawn square in
front of the other item for his a great
outpost yeah it is and after Queen of
five now the f4
has problems like should it go back
probably because there is no others
where though Anna comes for Bishop III
mmm I don't like that very much because
knight on d4 is very strong and black
still has problem what to do with the
night another just the white has just
one bad piece sort of a bad piece in the
position which is G drink nice and with
Queen big one this night will join in to
join the game with Knights gf5 it looks
very nice for white I agree with you the
night the tune is coordinating very
mother Orchestra will be fine and on the
third night it might have to appear on
g3 in the future now what is dumping
heavy pieces on the open e file
everything is looking great for absent
runs she has a three point lead I just
remind everybody that this is the very
final moments a few more games and we
will be done with this time controls 5+1
there will be one or two more games
depending on how long those games were
lost and it's a three point lead for the
former world champion yeah I'm impressed
ibly white place she wants to use all
advantages all squares though I would
think that it would be nicer but I think
Alexander knows better
I just think that it would be nicer to
have the knight and f5 already and then
maybe think of route g3 or I even
thought of some ideas like g4 but with
Queens on the board now not very much
because after Knight a5 rook g3 there is
96 good defense and I think that things
became easier or black I agree with you
I didn't really like Alexander's
decision I was going for Queen 65 this
simplification that connected the corner
D and B pose now hanging pawns on beef
identified and is located aged more very
important by and as a transcript
to get rid of the l4 weakness and now
this rook is more active than their
white rook the king is controlling
importance
this is now turning tables there's a
threat night big city because of the pin
on the second yeah and we see how
expressive Aleksandra is she's shaking
her head and she she made her eyes open
why she is not happy with the decision
and she clearly understood that she
missed something and from a very good
position she now gave up the initiative
yes this is a difficult moment for
Alexandra and the tendency is not the
one who are looking for she had the
pressure here this time in that position
and now suddenly she has to be defending
doesn't mean that her position is
vanished she still has more than two
minutes so her time management is once
again incredibly well done
it is Anna who gets into tangible every
single game 22 seconds left for the US
Champion for Tanya's champion 94 and she
shall be very good 60 seconds oh yeah h4
though is a nice move
because then while black would get some
squares on the kingside but it is huh it
is all right even if they are isolated
it is still a nice tough or 90 for the
progression is report but it is this
extra phone that make this position
difficult to defend for Ana the beep
husband especially is the problem yeah
now I think in this match we see how
important it is to have correct time
management because yes both players are
very strong with when you have good
position you still need to these seconds
to take correct decision we've seen that
from initiative black hat
because I think because of the time
pressure
ana ended up to be pond down in this
game and now she could take the h4 at
home at the beat one is running so if
you had taken on each one with the root
or the king bee stings p7 and the powers
on stubble or she is aiming for the beta
square to block the pole that's the only
way but this is looking
if you have to place your might all be a
it does because 96 is great it really
defends the b7 pawn and after rook c8
oh that's it but the position to be fair
the position is not started because of
rook c8 and opponent for most or units
tonight yeah it is four-point lead for
chest Queen indeed Allison is really
extremely well for this first segment
that was supposed to be the closest
according to our smarter just
predictions well sometimes we fail in
the start but it's exciting chance we
did not say with that prediction that
this may be the last game learn a lot
about one game in the fire pass one for
sure depending on the length of this
game yeah it depends on if things go bad
again for Anna then she should be east
marks to resign foster to have one more
possibility to play the game though it
is very difficult to bounce back in this
match but I have a feeling that three
plus one boom should go better for Anna
and we will see much more ups and downs
quite possibly and so far this is an
opening that could lead to anything
White has a pleasant position with the
fear captain fish of the night on before
fighting against the island so this game
could go in favor of Anna even then even
if she wins this game it'll be a
three-point difference but at least it
gives you a confidence boost and this so
needed in chess it's tomatoes I called
it so yes it is very much about the
psychology when you feel good the game
goes good as well and when you feel
prepared I think in chess it's very
important to fill that you're prepared
and it doesn't matter it happens on the
board or not but you feel that you need
some work before the game is very very
important
94 after 94 I think there might be some
ideas connected with c4 but I think it's
better
first to prepare it and not play it
directly though if you give time to
black then Bishop f6 rook c8 if Luke CH
work support happens it won't be easy
for white so maybe maybe it is time to
go see for right now I really do that
that porn is opponent you want to get
rid of this is a weakness and also we
shall see what's going to happen on the
long diagonal it is more than a moment
there and I speaking one time she has
been playing slowly all these games to
emphasize already dead Alex and Tempest
and you has been doing an amazing job
with time management every single time
even in the difficult position she had
she kept on playing quickly which is
good heading into the 3+1 portion then
you have even less time yeah and I think
we've we really believe that Alexander's
favorite timing is time control is three
plus one because we see that she has
five millions at the end of the game she
always has like two minutes left on the
clock
the 19:05 is usually very nicely placed
be because it's so close to the
opponent's king and takes a very
important squares from your opponent's
pieces not easy to get rid of this
Knight to change the way usually because
then we can see h6 square there's either
a check or then sometimes there's a pawn
on e6 and that's why you can't push that
an annoying piece yeah
it isn't this exponent you mentioned is
Disick's square sorry is very important
though not that important to give up the
bishop for it so don't think of Bishop
c4 d 6496 type of moves because it would
kind of now black has isolated fall and
then it would change flat structure so
it wouldn't be that great or white
quickly I like that very much because
then we have to decide what's to do with
the knight 96 do you think we should
play 96 it's one of the options for sure
because we definitely don't want to go
we squares it the night 96 is the most
active the question will be the straight
what happens if it's para wishes for
most players
the rookies hanging on d8 would be a
natural way to react to it
attack the pressure of defender
deformation and that is defending
balanced position in my opinion yeah and
only think I don't like after Bishop d6
58 is that black also might have after
Bishop and for Bishop e6 winner with
Bishop c4 and then it would be really
difficult for what to do something and I
don't know where so the question is when
there was something better than 92 Dean
696 simplifies the position but
depending an event for it different so
many squares available for the night so
she decides to go for the trade and your
maneuver is on the horse Jenica yeah it
is on the board it was very tempting to
activate the bishop because now the
bishop on c4 is way better than the
bishop on b7 and also you block the c3
pawn there are no more ideas with c4 and
now I think it's black again who has
initiative because of b v a5 coming
between a 5 rooks eh I really want
blacks position me to this spawn storm
quite possibly the Queen's that I do not
coming to the seat but everything is
very instructive on how Alex sometimes
we use the last couple of moves in order
to improve her position by White's
position that was very pleasant earlier
is now inferior because of its seats
upon the state on the board some people
told you guys that you should you should
put that pone until you can now try to
push the pawn
yeah it's not so easy it's really
difficult when you have bishop right
there before I think that's the only way
to continue the game otherwise a black
would just put all her pieces on ideal
squares and after D takes e4 bishop or
at least a White has some open diagonals
though what I dislike is the peen on d5
totally dust
in the position pressure over both the D
and the C files better place pieces in
terms of how the minor pieces are on the
board for web and the queen is real
active on each file so this is a lot of
pressure on Anna who is trailing it's
four points a four-point lead for
Alexander costing you this mainly the
last game in this game goes on for a
minute and a half and this will be the
final game of the five minutes plus one
second portion after which the players
will have a short break and we are back
with 3 plus 1 and 1 plus 1 right
is there a rook C for now because rook
e8 was pips like I thought like mix T
for root support Bishop h7 King h7
create but it doesn't bring anything
we're losing the d4 yeah there's nothing
going on I think I'll still like blacks
position and before white has the d4
pawn pretty weak in end games sometimes
it turns to be strength because it's a
faster fun but when there are bishops
and queens on the board I think that
Depot pony's weakness and especially
this position it should be now better
for whites to defend it but still it's
very difficult yeah there appear in the
second line which is always good news
plus white has problems with the
background because of this very well
placed Queen so she pushes each or was
still it's a bit problematic we
suggested having pieces not wanting
pressure on the action square as well so
as Center has taken initiative one more
time
yeah and a teaspoon also White has to
take care of the a 2.25 now can be
played but good manner for white should
be 25 Rick see one back look see - I
like it very much
23 and now maybe clean rook a to just
upon for research I'm gonna use
something the chip does Ghana my
chocolate salami my next comment imagine
there's a chocolate students
we're thinking about which satisfy it
alright back to the game looks similar
obviously wanted to get better but has
been lost but so far its opponent for
black and it's troublesome anyway to
abandon the veteran like is not analytic
seeker as a trade on c2 potentially and
this Queen and game is still problematic
even if you win this pawn when I was
seven
it is so dangerous the quality we have
between the pawns is quite a striking
difference plus black is going to win
the D pawn and still have this very
strong support for yeah especially when
C pawn is on c4 it can be very fast even
maybe we don't even need to take on d4
and placing cream right away with the
idea in d 1c to check and very quickly
Queenie
so that's really not what should happen
though it is on the board as far as I
see and that's what happens c3 there was
there is no needs to give in check and
then check and see to it is lost even
better than the line I was showing why
don't you just push the pawn and not
care about the d4 I'm very instructive
it's about the quality of the puzzle is
not the quantity that's what I'm
referring to in my upcoming course I
actually just recorded a video when this
very same topic in Queen Anne games a
few days ago so spoiler from me there I
start this in videos of mine already
that are not out yet after this the
problem is that this postponed is going
to promote there's one problem for black
and that is the threat of the perpetual
check zone but it's doing very well in
keeping an eye on the f5 squares and
fasds squares that is those are the
potential for chexquest
[Music]
seconds oh my god
d5 ponies lost okay there is really this
was the last game lowest game it's a 5-1
days for Alexandra coast and you we are
going to go for the next session that is
an hour of three minutes plus one second
which games but before there
for sure brain and so army join us in a
few minutes don't go anywhere we are
just going to grab some chocolate and
don't forget to click the mothers
definitely clips and also the question
of the day and then we'll see you in a
few minutes
do stay tuned
[Music]
Ches calm is about playing at any moment
there are thousands of people from
around the world playing on Ches comm so
whether you're a total beginner or a
grandmaster you'll find a game quickly
with someone at your level you can play
at any pace from one minute bullet to
five-minute blitz to 60 minute games or
you can play more relaxed games where
you have several days to make your move
there are tournaments starting every few
minutes or you can play against our
customizable coaching computer chess
comm is for learning chess isn't just
about playing it's about getting better
chest out compos the best training tools
at your fingertips sharpen your game
with over fifty thousand tactics puzzles
improve your strategy with training
videos by top grandmasters get instant
feedback after your games with real-time
computer analysis regardless of where
you're at now you can take your game to
the next level chess comm is for sharing
join the community where you can discuss
chess ideas in the forums and follow the
latest chest news or join a club with
friends and playing a league against
other clubs you can find all this in
your browser at home and at work or
on-the-go with your phone or tablet
signing up is free and easy so what are
you waiting for enjoy your game
welcome to the second match of the
women's speed chess championship this is
the match between aleksandr kots and you
and Ana Szczepanski so before I myself
are covering the nighttime we are so
thrilled to be here we are indeed and so
for the match was pretty good for
Alexandra because she has five point
lead but I think that Ana will come back
in the coming portion it may be the case
and we also want to remind you of what's
coming up next
tomorrow's match is also a big one will
be the favorite there Valentina Lena I'm
gonna crush oh I don't know because I
think that Valentina she is really a big
professional of bleach and she wants to
play please she is very strong
also I arena crush she's she's into
bleach games very much so we'll have
very fighting in the exciting match but
I still think that Valentina Kalina
might be a slight favorite I also think
she's favorite she's very good in
speeches in Berlin online chess - but
Irina is a fighter and she she is has
won the US Women's Championship multiple
times so what we see is yes today and
tomorrow it's basically two players aldi
only big team of Russia facing two
players on the Olympic team of the US
yeah and that's actually great to see
it's like a thematic match between USA
and Russia but Valentina Galina will be
also playing the candidates tournament
which is starting very soon in three
days and actually there are four players
from Russia there is one Georgian and I
actually wish all of them good luck it's
going to be very exciting tournament but
before we have important matches indeed
so we will be covering all the matches
on the human speed chess championship we
have just in the schedule the player
that will win today so far it's looking
like it's going to be just minimizing
the cost and you will make it to the
semi-finals and main price the price
found for this event is $20,000 whoo
that's
lots of money and in the pre-match
interview actually Alexandra was asked
what you've gotta do with the money if
you need to send it in one day again
should be questioned it was the final
price really not too much money buddy
she wins the whole event and actually
that's a very difficult question because
like you have to have something in mind
if you really want but if you don't want
anything then it's difficult to come up
with something in a second so she said
first of all that she didn't but I think
she was pleasantly surprised and she
said that she would spend it unusual
stuff like women stop jewelry makeup
bags and so on and she also said that
she what she didn't actually know their
prices that much because she wanted to
participate in this event anyhow he had
to support women chairs and support the
initiative of Chester come to bring on
more top class women tournaments and
that's very nice of her such mudal like
alexandra she herself been a model like
a real model and model of chess she is
doing everything to promote women's
chest as well as honor she is doing a
lot of things and though there was a
very nice gesture from her in the
beginning but the game already started
and I think we have to take a look what
happens I was gonna say that this is a
you know drink in the open category even
I know it so people that Knight c3 is
not the best move for my because it
cannot be fine you can take this point
because you will lose the room so be
nice if it's not the best move because
of allowing b5 right either it is some
deep preparation or Aleksandra just
forgot it's that b5 is there and it's
not the end of the course but as we see
it is way easier for black to develop
and she managed to put c5 in one go like
b4 b5 P 4 C 5 that's the main idea of
this game for black
and she managed to do with tempest in
one go
that's very important of course in this
stage of the game that black will serve
you Tempe for her development and now it
is trade only for we shall see
Blackwell wants to take all play nice
assist attack the Queen develop the
knight still there are some issues in
the position but so far is looking good
for any terms of getting that equalizing
position the time the time situation is
already in favor of Alexander and it was
one it's gonna be a bigger issue oh yeah
it's going to be really important and I
like the way Alexandra is playing
because she's buried fast and she she
doesn't really nice the tricky tactics
so it's really saying that she's just
win at the moment but anna has time to
fight back because she is a big fighter
and we've seen a lot of games where she
she's just you know fighting she has
this fighting spirit and it doesn't
matter what kind of position she has she
will just play till the end true it's a
funny situation currently on the board
with so many pieces on the background
but Bishop da makes a lot of sense to
force might do something about this mind
on a fire because why is controlling the
c6 creditos tonight you want to develop
you want your pieces to have more
freedom after then I'm going back fine
I'd like to play Knight to c6
yeah and that was very nice way to free
the position and to develop as much
pieces or trade it is better for black
because one already has C file and
Whitey's a beat black is at health in
the development so far I can say so good
for Anna because now Knight b3 is not
doing that much but I don't know if this
game will be the turning point she badly
needs to start winning games it's a
five-point lead for Alexandra continued
with only half of the match ahead of us
that is
one hour session of three plus one bit
and then half an hour for the blue yes
dan bull and there really has to be very
fast yeah oh but Alison there's just
such a beast in plates and speeches in
general yeah she is
I've seen her video when she was she
covered all chest squares on board
squares I think in like with night in Y
ten seconds
oh that you need to jump to every square
with the night but the only can touch
yes I am not sure but she she was really
very fast you give me an hour and I
still be thinking every square plus by
the nine you can only move to every
square ones and you need to cover the
64's clip it yeah and just part of the
process that you like because we will
choose the moment of the day after this
segments you have a bit less than an
hour to choose which is your favorite
moment of the day and we will have a
look at the clips the Chester's Khan
team is already working on watching
those pins and your feedback on Twitter
as I use the hashtag speech just tell us
about your opinion on the question of
the day as well right and now again in
this position I think black is doing
very fine but I don't see also big big
problems for white as well only thing
that I can say is that this seed file is
White's under blacks favor and if white
plays be free which is very much needed
to to support to the a4 form then it
will weaken the c3 square so now we have
very different situations because of the
situation because the roots are gone and
be free was needed not to allow white to
play be free and trades and be found
this should be an easy draw it should be
example if either clear
going really down on time so have longer
we still have a midnight on the board
and done stochastic for Hannah's Yankee
why did she okay she used to be able to
now take on a four yeah okay she could
have taken when do you look to what she
was something still but was this route
chain would leave a simple Michael you
even if the night was going to be in the
corner with the roof still on the board
and dispassion the seventh man 80
seconds left for Anna as five nights
coming in this is going to be because
every time I say this is going to be an
easy draw somehow somehow it doesn't
attend in easy drawn yeah and there's a
fourth option on e6 she prevented it but
[Music]
that was just just silicon's yeah the
first game of the 3+1 segment won by a
nosotros which was very much needed
let's see this can be the turning points
yeah we would love to show you the
moment version did not move there but
there's no actually because the next
game is on and a bounces back with this
one but still a way to go it's about
four more points and very good as Matt -
for support point lead still for the
chest wait I took you to teach maths -
Danny yeah okay so
we're quietly still a lot ana has to be
still four more games to level the match
score and then we'll see what happens
but it's not easy just it's the first
time we've seen in this match that
Alexandra plundered so easily
yes we saw blunders by ana earlier when
she planted the piece and then in one
game even her Queen and Alexandra as you
mentioned she played very good just even
a trench it was in verse positions she
would make sure she does not go for a
tactical not exactly and it's first time
we've seen Alexander front wondering
maybe it's time for snacks for her does
she get to be in a moment both players
are prepared they have snacks right next
to the computer we have an X under
leaving a cookie right before the show
yeah it was and I was like what are you
saying
it's so yummy in this position though
once again we see quite a symmetrical
position the one difference being a
little bit on how this e4 poll gives
more space
the whites pieces by the east exponents
blocking the CM bishop for the moment
and if you push it fire thinking then
that's no happy develop your pieces will
give up the d5 square which is really
important
yeah I agree with you and once again we
see nice position for Ana so far wait at
the time she is doing very fine she
didn't take a lot of times where she has
still two minutes on the clock and
hopefully files for the rooks big
problem for black is they see a t-shirt
and I like this d6 square very much as
well I can find maybe a look at e6 work
d1 at some point I think White's pieces
are nicely placed but there is always
space to the improve right indeed now
after the Queen's were traded on June 5
this is the current position where like
it's just coming to develop the see a
pitcher
yeah and b6 Bishop e7 would be the
natural way but then d7 square you would
give up the D stands for which is very
important you shouldn't allow on seventh
rank that's why 95 was played and after
95 that was very nice that Alexander
could play Bishop d7 and bishops exist
this is way better than mrs. Bishop
itself I really did was crucial and it
takes not time for Anna to bring the
bishop from f3 to g2 in order to be able
to push the f1 and now if I still some
pressure on Alexander but the position
has include an innocent achievements to
be a bishop yeah the position simplified
and I still like White's position
because of this space
so there is one thing that white should
be careful I know that my opponent looks
very attractive and why always tries to
push the pawn to e5 to get the these six
square but the thing is that in endgame
it might be actually a weakness because
it is very much at once fun and pawns
can it go back
so if black manages to go F 6 fvfv that
would be a very weak one yes it also has
its drawbacks as sabi ko mention whether
that can get f6 and take on e5 will be
the question in the future so far mine
is in important d6 square but alone that
will not change the pollution that was
especially when you see that with the
knight on f6 that can and will push up
six yeah so after b v a5 is a smart way
because you don't want to open the a
file for the rook and you cannot get to
b5 so easily there was one thing that
maybe white could take a Bab 96 FB 95
but the problem was that our b3 home is
also weak so you win the Pampas you lose
be trip on after route p8 f6 was played
even with a nice two d6s the paper
mention if black can take on in five
that would weaken that form
and that's why and decides to capture on
our six now that will give some relief
to like there's no more ninety six jobs
that we don't know the position yeah and
we have the daily question on the screen
just a reminder that your opinion is
very important so please tell us what do
you think what chess community should be
doing to grow woman's chest indeed and
we do appreciate any ideas as you can
see this is the first women's pictures
championship and that's one of the many
ways in which chamber form is helping to
promote women's chest more girls and
more women to play chess whether is a
profession that there is a sport over
there is a hobby I don't think that
really matters as long as people like
chess and I would love to see more girls
and what women in chess in general oh I
agree with you and it's it's it's very
good sport even if you're not going to
fight professionally it helps you in
life as well life decisions like when
you're about to make a big life decision
if you're a chess player you would
always think about rows and columns you
would take your time and then make a
move in your life but if you're not to
just play you hurry up a bit I agree
with you that chess peaches so many in
life skill and if you want to know more
about the parallels between chest and
laugh and pick up garriga's for his
books for instance how laughing it is
chess oh that's very nice one and I'm
happy
remember that okay ready though about
10-15 years ago so minutes so we have
King III and we'll be five now a bit of
problem on Ava I have a funny feeling
that Black Keys overtaking or h6 bone is
too weak so there is always 97 96 I
don't know maybe it was better to play
97 96 instead of taking the pawn on b4
because there could have been a
possibility although we will not have
time unfortunate to go back because now
the current situation is that it's nine
seven that Center for the first time in
the
she is under time pressure yeah that's
Wow
what is happening first time would seem
that she blundered in the first game
after the break and now she has less
time than Hana yes and this shows
something into Sigma even if they now
end up repeating three times
I think well we are witnessing that yes
even an accent I can crack under
pressure she dips under once I'll never
change out of things d5 and it's not my
feelings
Ayane goes for play and that's what I
mean that she's had a fighting
experience she doesn't give up and give
a half on incident so easily she just
wants that opponents really equalizes
nine ten games can be very tricky always
because it can jump to both wears white
and black ones and it can be very tricky
for both sides actually and now look at
these knives both are paralyzing the
other innocent that before attacking
yeah the two pawns and after the H pawns
for this is a very well thought game
they were trying both players were
trying but now the only thing that one
needs to do is to give up her night for
the remaining four all black and then
it's a handshake but for the first time
is so Alex internal temperatures yes
good sign for Emma yeah indeed that's a
good sign
this game is drawn very solid nice game
and let's see how this segment will go
for Ana's Adamski who is four points
points down in the match disadvantage
but it's still 40 minutes left from this
segment that's many many big games
Scandinavia now we have on the board
this is the opening that Anna is using
time to time but usually she plays
either French a sperm a reporter or
Patrick with off a big line with Knight
f6 this is the line which she is not
using so much but I think she just
prepared for
to bathe and she was thinking if I'm
done because you you have to think of
different strategies like if you are
four points down maybe you need more
energetic and active opening to get back
into the match if you're leading then
you can stick the pattern or French so I
think we take her down and the French
depresses them wander I think if
Alexandra had had the time to prepare
she definitely prepared for the French
defense so if I chose not to go for your
main opening in which case anyone and
you really want to surprise your
opponent when you are trailing 4 points
advantage for Alexandra yeah and
Alexandra played everything all sorts of
new orders before superlative 3e4 she
can play g3 bursts but we can see in
bullet mm-hmm now this is a developing
moves with a check after which the good
castle but this Bishop can sometimes be
in trouble they move like five oh yeah
Castle is pretty dangerous because as
you mentioned f5 but so far can it be
the case that when the king is very nice
in the center I really do h5 and I is
about to open the H file but Empire
counterpunch to England this Bishop is
the problem piece yeah there's a
potential piece sacrifice here hg hg
rook h3 what's going on
kingi to and I don't know maybe long
castle to get another routine to the
game with Luke H AIDS and Luke h2 very
interesting let's see if the players
will go for it
after f5 Anna Anna has played Bishop
lasers and you will not see the P
sacrifices that there's a capture only
six and the H file is still about the
I thought that this kind of sacrifices
are very nice in pleased games and
especially online chess because you have
the initiative and initiative is very
important when your opponent has not so
much time to defend but honest choice o
is also very interesting because now we
see what I said before that if I might
be weak and this is I think the case
when advanced pawns are not always best
bonds
I fully really demand we shall see
what's going to happen if there's a
capture on g4 the only thing it's not
working immediately for black to go for
a tray damage of a file to win the age
born there's a chap on a fall so that we
can move over it is the exchange of new
files also comes to mind
yeah because then blacks King would be
also very weak because it's in the
center Bishop g5 was actually a very
smart move
each restricts black from hustling once
long side which is very much needed
because now it is great on what happens
but we definitely need another rook into
the game and into the attack she only
got a big picking of the c3 pawn and
then there's a queen trait opposite
colored bishops but who's skiing is
immoral here wow that's a very very nice
jisuk stupid yeah then on the f5 and
that's nice
[Music]
c6 still saves the people beautiful that
is our motive I just couldn't take it
because it exactly with have my check
and then you take then you pick up the
bishop can I draw them divert oh yes
there it is yeah indeed but I we have to
mention a very active direct play from
chess Queen right away not caring about
pawns trading the Queen's and then using
the B file
rupee one rupee
seven pointing out that not only my king
is weak but your king is also in trouble
that was indeed very impressive yes and
was left on the world is unfortunately
not that exciting anymore it's opposite
colored bishops and endgame that will
lead to a jewel equal pawns but even
with an extra phone right now for black
this is easy to defend with political
ambitions yeah and Alexandra is very
experienced please player and very good
at tricks as well as I'm as don't ski
because she is most of the time in time
trouble and when you're in time trouble
you see tactics easily because you are
all about not to blunder anything
because you were in time travel so we
had really fighting game yes and I just
wanted to end it it was Anna who offered
enjoying this end game even though she's
Epona it's obviously a jewel position
and time matters it's only a bit over
half an hour left from this time and she
badly needs to start new games to bounce
back and have a chance in the match
exactly and we have again the impetus on
the board now it is on appellees with
white pieces Alexander was using it in
the first few games it seems that it's
very popular nowadays in blitz that's
you it's easier to play anyway you know
what to do like you put the bishop on g2
you put the bishop on beaches and then
you play in the center and you really
want to get this knight on e5 I agree
fully with everything you mentioned and
now has to see fire the problem is yeah
we are leaving of only five square we
are creating another default from black
if you think back with the night if we
take c5 which is the other option yes
that connects the pawns but leaves their
mind on a six of that had to make a
choice which one is preferable do you
want a nicer than Poland bring the
knight oh really
connect your pawns but keep still there
Knight
on the rim so you will need to jump to
before in the
future yeah and as an isolated pond as
well as in hanging pawns the rule is
that you should not trade pieces you
should use the hanging pawns with the
pieces try to attack because all these
breakthroughs with deep or seaport and
opening up diagonals for pieces might be
useful for you but if you don't have
pieces then you are in trouble because
hanging pawns actually they are
weaknesses in the position this is very
very very typical what is happening in
this game with d4 and c4 there are
Indian games on Garry Kasparov with
hanging pawns and a lot of a lot of
typical games mostly what white is
trying is to break this up on Shane with
III and point over already has B 3 so C
4 squared we can use but to be honest I
like blacks initiative I also like it
even though the knight is on the ring
but it's very easy to visualize them
position that you get your night to be
small the long diagonal is great if you
can put even more pressure on it perfect
the not only four is very well placed
and as you said what I should be aiming
for is to tear those bones apart if you
can get in a p4 or easily palm push in
the right moment that would be great for
white but it's not happening anytime in
the near future and the night comes into
p4 very active pieces for black that
will cause problem for Anna
so alexandra is bouncing back from this
difficult situation where she was under
pressure she lost her first game in in a
way that was unexpected yes Italy not
Messina her group was handy yeah that
also caused a couple of clips I believe
yeah make sure to tweet them as well use
the hashtag speeches and keep on
clipping because we are looking for the
moment of the day even if it may have
happened already who knows oh yeah but
for me the moment of the match was the
moment when you scare me
over here first the Handy's will be
referring to I'm sure that then is a
candidate for a moment of the data we
may still experience even more exciting
moments in the Google ocean which is
coming up after the 3+1 bridge there's
half an hour left from this settlement
and it's a four-point lead for accent
Lacoste and you will and as I don't ski
bounce back that was not in the chat
your opinion do you think it will be a
close match or X and I will manage to
win very confidently we want to know who
you are rooting for and we are
monitoring the chat on chest TV and
twitch so make sure to talk to us yeah
do that
III is on the board so Anna is trying to
tear these pawns and pawn chain now the
problem is that black annotate TJX III
as the knight is hanging so a bishop e4
comes to my mind but once again if black
does not manage to do something about
the pawn chain then we might see
Alexandra in trouble so what I think do
you think piece of E for Queen let's say
D to Queen d5 might be acquitted for
play and they may end up repeating most
if not it should things be three I don't
know it's also interesting to go Bishop
before Queen d2 right and 25 then we
take a takes d4 and is repeating so it
sees that Anna would be happy with the
draw from this position she has 24
seconds left and she may not be dead
happy about how this little game for
that yeah King a chase
Aleksandra goes for on sacrifice because
after King h8 y can take he takes before
CJ 64 Queen d4 she is attracted with 92
she has a tactic because
motive winning the roof on Sivan that
was beautifully played high in a chest
queen yeah it was really nice 92 was a
little trick and splat 1 so Alexandra
has known 5 point lead
that's a lot now that is a response
Alexandra to everyone in the jet who may
have said that it's gonna be a close
match I see my native supporting acts
and of course I'm just stealing you and
also make sure that you go over your
mouse over the screen where you see the
broadcast under here and then you can
click on an exodus channel because she
does three mantras regularly make sure
to support her Channel yeah and actually
we are really spoiled this time just
community that world champion like
Alexandra - Cara Nakamura is also
streaming but she admits in Russia
Lavrov is also streaming even Martin
started to stream it's a golden era for
chess I am really you that we are living
in the era where everyone streams and
that should mean that you ladies will
also start your own twitch channel I
arrived today in the middle and I want
it guys oh my gonna happen so what we
have we have castle and same motives
with Bishop Dean frequency - like we had
in the game Alexandra used it already
this Gospels against Anna with age 393
but now 90s on e 2 and F 4 is tiny beat
you move a new in sense that they
usually white goes here at 3 and Ricky
one maybe a four was mostly or maybe
it's just an idea not aware hmm and good
question I was a little distracted
because I see that the chat is going to
suggest your channel name she has
already registered on Twitch which is
the first step so because it does have a
twitch usernames
we just need to set up a channel and I
think it's going to happen in the coming
days
yeah is well
I promise I promise it and maybe you
play bullet hmm all right once we stream
on your channel I'm going to be playing
bullet on your show
okay do deal that's nice one nice so
easy to make business with you
yeah I'm pretty lean it's happening guys
now because we have first you know first
show on Twitch in the coming days I
think tomorrow we can announce a day so
we would discuss there you can do it
tomorrow remember there's another match
that is coming up in government speeches
championship between parents in Akutan
and Irene a crush
let us know how do you see that imagine
who will be rooting for today and
tomorrow
it's two members of the Russian Olympic
team versus two members of the US
Olympic team it is who it's a very very
tense match with Russians and Ukrainians
playing against each other but so far
alexandra is doing very good because of
5.8 but still a lot of time a little
time and a bullet section is coming up
who he's the fastest just playing
I feel like absence will do very well
and good as well so Anna badly needs to
bounce back already in this section
yeah I really do five-point lead is huge
and when it happens in the game just the
rookies gone some how did that happen I
look at the chat for a moment and then
the rook is gone alright Bishop before
was missed in a sense that the moment
the tactical motive for taking on d5 to
win the look on a a excellent job once
again on fire her tactical skills have
always been extremely strong that's one
of her best skills and players were all
actually about what do they consider the
strengths and weaknesses of their
opponents Alex have you talked about
Anna and what she said that the biggest
strength of enemies is that she's a very
experienced player and yeah weakness
remember what she
yeah she said that she's spending a lot
of time on chest Alexandre because she's
professional chess player and is also
professional chess player but she has
family she has two kids and she probably
is not working on chess because of
family as much as needed
so in chess it's always useful to know
your opponent's family situation and
adjust but we did see in the previous
match to that Katarina not know one of
the top female players and said that she
always wanted us World Championship
being classic all chance a few months
ago she completed she didn't qualify she
didn't make it through and she had to
master her children she's got four kids
and they were hanging around her amazing
I was insisting to break her and so that
she tells me what is the secret that
she's playing so good after having four
kids and sport of them to take care of
them family and then just qualifying in
the finals of World Championship Women's
World Championship then really world
women bleeds championship that was
amazing she should know we don't know
the secret she just know that she didn't
play with chest she's very hard on
herself a little be rooting for Katya I
know the rest of the players Alexandra
to in the candidate which is starting in
just three days in Kazan that's where
most of these top FINA players are
having an Alexander to has been focusing
on her preparation for the limits
candidates tournament that's why she
said that she will not do any particular
preparation for today but she has been
playing a lot on chance platform and see
me competing in the Tuesday's event
another point that Tuesday so I think it
goes to show that she's very comfortable
on gender calm yeah definitely I've seen
one of her streams and she was very nice
she had a very smooth stream and as you
mentioned she played a lot of
tournaments as well and I think she
really enjoys it
yeah she does not play online I think
the Streamy even ended to death so she
has always been playing quite
online yeah and after she started
streaming it's an additional feature
that you can even see her reactions you
can talk to her while she's competing
yeah and it's amazing that she is a an
active player she streams and she's
playing a lot of plays and she is as
well a commentator she human say today
women world's championship she was first
played there and then she commentated
with her husband to group of a the world
Women's Championship when she was not
out yes
now this position it's equal material on
the board but there's a danger because
of the plaquing situation the queen and
the night are very strong together so
accent is trying to get something out of
this position is she managed tricking as
imesh biking games are always tricky
it's an honor has 10 seconds on the
board and the phone is gone second one
can second one go though we still have
equal material because two against one
of the kingside would eat these very
tricky because after a three King III is
not possible she's of 92 it may be can
it be because she was looking between
limiting the pawn oh3 that's a very nice
nice move now 94 this is transport honor
to grab points
definitely King explore why not Kingdom
for yeah that wasn't possibility to have
to work the Jeep on but clearly push
them too hard in these games you want to
win so badly and not she resigns she
resigns h3 yeah and King g5 that is a
better move than what we thought coming
closer with the key it does take away in
both of these squares and h3 you cannot
stop the poem between not yet so
instructed playing in a second and as we
know the king opposes night they see is
a very nice opposition with King g5 and
key for versus nineteen seven also very
fun four-point lead for Allison because
when you
but with this victory at least the
confidence is coming back for Anna it
has been a tough shake up a little bit
Aleksandra cycle psychology matters
so much it just so anything can still
happen 20 minutes left for this segment
remember yeah it does and both of them
have to be very feet to seat or three
hours look at the screen and where there
is a lot of we are joining us from where
are you tuning you from which city which
country because we do love to see how
international the chest community is and
make sure to answer the daily question
the hashtag speeches on why do you think
or how do you think we could improve
women's chest in general what can we do
to promote and get more into chest in
terms of girls and women starting to
play this game I think I go half a more
sport doesn't really matter
exactly and we do know from which cities
players are playing Alexandra is home so
she is playing from Moscow well she said
it in her pre-interview pre match
interview and I think Anna is also home
she lives in Germany so she is playing
from Germany and we're in-laws
we are in Holland I arrived today and I
am very happy to be here there's no web
can go between us we are in the same
room yeah just for three hours when you
go back to base back to the place where
is no basement actually there is
basement decorated with chocolate in
terms of this position it is so far and
very interesting middle game position
with chances for both sides and also in
terms of the management very balanced
good news for an ellipse she managed to
speed up after the first couple of games
where she was struggling
I'm yeah definitely and after this trade
I have to say that I think white is
doing good because I'm saying
94 and a bit of it would be slightly and
I don't even know if I have to say that
it is hanging pawns but it looks like it
would be difficult hanging upon if we
had a funnel d2 instead of ONC two semi
hanging ball the tradition hanging pond
will be this point is not one see the
less I think I was talking about it if
it was an e2 that would be done and
infrastructure now it doesn't matter
anymore because they are suddenly
connected pawns changing picture still
some pressure over a c6 pond that's why
rook e1 will be six was played yeah I
have to say that I don't like this
change very much for black I thought
that it would be nicer to take oh she
couldn't take it with Ben I'm sorry
because the root was hanging but forcing
like to take with the pond getting to
the e5 square and I think Bishop is
better than the night because now there
is no epsilon phone there cannot be g6
played so these diagonal b1h second
diagonal might become very important 26
I don't think that white should allow
the trade rookie 5 can be the move but
then
97 is the problem so 26 is good move
with black but I still like points
position I think that white has great
initiative and I like the gene work yes
with the four point disadvantage and I
will definitely try to use this game for
at least in decreasing that advantage
and Alexandre has over her it's gonna be
about still time from trying to pump it
demands in 17 minutes
you can please do a couple of more games
and ideally and I would like to enter
the blood portion with a minimal
disadvantage if not a tie score yeah
title would be ideal though four points
a
a lot as you said but so far things look
better in this time control for anagen
in five plus one that also can be a
little treat from Anna that she made her
opponents think that okay this is going
to be an easily match because I have
five point lead but and she goes in
beastmen I think if it was done on
purpose that's brilliant but I'm afraid
it's more that she hasn't had much time
to practice she doesn't play much online
and as she's going through this game
she's warming herself oh yeah so she's
speeding up because she has been playing
already for an hour and a half and it
goes to show that she's capable of
playing really quick very strong
tactical moves as well but she didn't
have the practice yeah that is true and
online practice is very different from
the real chess practice because there is
no mouse there can it be mouse leaves
then you can just throw pieces on your
opium bullet and which is not possible
in online chests but all I just became
very popular I think it also helps a lot
when you're playing bleats online and
when you're practicing it makes you
sharper you see these little tactics
very easily so it's very much I think
it's very much recommended to play
online though you should not only play
all the time online you should also do
other things like study solve tactics
puzzle brush have you tried puzzle one
more time we are entering the game where
she is under time pressure 24 seconds
for an Oslo time situation is critical
for both players
kingi 4 and I my seed we check to pick
up the phone is it what she wanted now
my before is it check yes my pieces are
very active both boys are hanging as
after king c5
I was wondering route d7 was very very
necessary because after King survived it
would be double attack what wait
Luke sees oh it was white smooth sorry
yeah I thought that Rick see salmon is a
possibility and we were losing the rook
but it does look good or black or white
I'm not sure because we have nice
rapport as well yes we're going to say
that white is doing well but there's one
chance if this D post one starts moving
forward that is for course problematic
for right and a street born was a John
which is a passive move now look it is
possible yeah that was going to be
difficult and I would be too is next
move Bishop d-19 Peter King we have two
nice he wants to pick up the h3 poor
boom King c2 looking it the night comes
back to defend the point
Oh York c1 indeed okay five seconds on
the clock it's very understandable but
we we see that players are getting tired
abate it's a very difficult match a lot
of blunders are there and now it's one
point up for chess Queen but these
should be a draw because it is blocked
and even though I send is extremely
strong in tactics always find it yeah
under such pressure after so many years
but even she didn't see a simple tactic
that was the fork on f2 yeah usually
what happens is that you play the move
and then you're like oh my god that was
my tip - but you have to get it home for
it because if you think about it then it
is back for the game but alex is looking
do here even if he sends in them in the
draw position because she was already
trailing and now it's an even bigger
than this well I was gonna say that
should play on even if it's a jewel
because yeah uses time from the counter
but teasing incredible and I must on
time oh my god
that's very yeah we see that one second
is really nothing it's just when you
have a queen and you will mate and you
won't be flat but one second is not
enough time to think yes now this is
troublesome because it is one more time
a five-point lead for Alexandra Ksenia
13 minutes to go from this segment so
becoming quite clear that Alexandra will
enter the bullet with an advantage the
question is would it be a five-point
advantage will be a bigger than fine
point as well did you have a mess what
do you guys think that does know that
Jen do you see their actions I will keep
on collecting points or will she keep
this advantage will Ana managed to
bounce back yeah I I don't know because
it is very tough when you're also
already five points done you think that
you need a lot of points to catch up but
you try your best and ana really has to
be quicker and especially in bullet
section it would be very very difficult
to take your time maybe she will be
forced to not to spend any second any
extra second so we bullet will go better
for her but we also have to say that
Alexandra is playing very good and she's
very fast and she's very fast with
tactics and everything so difficult a
difficult match for an acetone skew so
far but we know that she has a very
faulty experience she's a fighter
so we hope that she will bounce back
that's the question whether she will be
able to in this position where she has
the black pieces it won't be simple
white has more space also if you see the
activity of the pieces with the Queen on
before the room joining the one and only
open cyanide h5 reckoning made on g7
first even
to defend this position and then try to
bounce back yeah that is true and 9h
five is very annoying probably Queen
your fate is one of the defense's well
at six you don't want to play because
then you give up the e six square Knight
f6 you also don't want to do ninety five
is another way and probably the best way
because after ninety five you don't want
to take with night because then after a
spore you will lose the night but it's
details in five I think will be the
middle but after even after D takes d5
Queen g4 and then Bishop geez thanks be
sure I don't know it might be tricky
still though like I still has 26
nightmare bishops yeah it's type of
moves right yes 95 only important move
in order to defend on the long diagonal
I wonder why she thinking she has
finally played the 65 is that I'm just
making moves on the board and now we
shall see that accent of place is her
Queen on ideas lest I become a smashing
oh yeah McShane 795 yeah I was thinking
about it though I thought that it it's
not very realistic because after 9525
queen of faith I did not see the way to
continue their attack maybe something
like Queen f5 or 24 ooh
C 5 C 5 isn't on the board so definitely
there was 7 is next what a beautiful
finish to this game look eh and
brilliantly by Alexandra pasta new
another blunder and Aleksandra is now 6
points leads she definitely enjoys what
happens and that dream what is that
energy dream I'm not sure it was about
the dreams the snacks and of course the
players can do whatever they like
Egan's freeman shall smile after it and
normally when you see the classical
economist daily Tony Mann School where
the board tournaments
people all the top players they have
their poker
things on because you don't want to
disturb you Reverend while in online
chess you can do whatever you like yeah
that's why you see kickers singing most
of the time you'll ever hit because
you're not disturbing your opponent's
that's not disrespectful it's great that
we can be observing the players or the
additional yeah entertainment but the
players are not seeing each other they
are not studying each other yeah and it
would be very unpleasant to after such
blunder and systems or opponent has a
big smile on her face nobody does nobody
does I think friend it's not for a big
your augment but online chess that's why
it's good that we can see their emotions
and Alexandra is pretty expressive
Catalina was not expressive at all and
she kept her poker face also in front of
camera which we were pretty surprised
and I think Anne is also express it the
less than Alexandra yeah before we move
on with this game and the match let's
just see some of the answers that you
guys have come up with to our daily
question according to channel can we
have one really interesting one so let's
see that response to our topic
that's currency guarantee a proper
commentary of main field tournaments
it's pretty disappointing to watch a
commentary very it's pretty obvious the
hosts are not even interested in women's
games hash tag speeches Wow the hash tag
is included because of the question and
that's how you can answer us obviously
topic and I are more than interested in
images that I do have believe in this
response because it's really not cool
then you see that the force would talk
about anything but women just like if
they if they talk about much test in a
way that they considered inferior yeah
for instance just an example and without
naming anyone that doesn't really draw a
nice picture of the event itself yeah
that is true
I agree with you and but nowadays I
don't think that's they do it yeah well
not right
yeah and we eat has been done and but
it's getting better but a great response
yeah and come up with more responses
about the topic woman's chest how can we
make sure that it's going to grow and
not decrease the number of finger
players because why are we so few yeah
everything everywhere I'm commenting the
organizers are asking why there are so
few women just players what is the
reason and this is what we are trying to
know with this question and if you
answer and if you share your thoughts we
will be able to get into the topic more
and maybe finally realize why there are
so few female players yes and what else
can we do as you see the women speeches
championship is one good example on how
has the forum and other platforms can
help to grow the the chess community and
get more women into chest by organizing
for instance such an event where the
price bound is $20,000 it's important
that top players female players can make
a living out of chess and for that they
need two tournaments yeah I agree with
you and because that's all they do they
play professional chess and they they
are also giving their best as male
players also play a good game fully
agreed now we need to get back to the
game because the players are down to a
minute and a half
it's probably a huge lead for eggs and
of course new six point lead with this
rookie a tactical motive in the game is
game a beautiful finished by the chest
Queen and still there's time at five
minutes left from this segment so this
is one of the last games of the 3+1
session in them
it's going to be fun there I'm expecting
a lot of blunders but we'll see so far
Alexandra is doing great having six
point lead which is a lot but still
bullet section is coming and in a minute
you can in six minutes
you can lose this six points so I don't
think should be 12 minutes but six
minutes yeah yeah okay relax and feel
that it matches over because there are
still bullets there is still bullet
section and a lot of things can happen
what happens in this game is is only
going to win this game because d6 pawn
is going to be very very dangerous
yeah this is an active ladies and
gentlemen and you need an active in it
MVM zurich is about to push other people
from the b7 square this is called a
parish rook and otherwise Kings will be
supporting the be postponed and even you
can end the claw responds yes and it's
very nice to see the manor with rookie 7
root P 7
as you mentioned pieces they Tarrasch me
but it also cuts the king from the from
coming and activating and this is
already very easy we were for Anna
because after d7 there are lots of
minutes there is breach that you can use
in this position but simple King c8 in
Group C 7 wood game most important is
that after trading black will sacrifice
of course the rook for the pawn most
important is that in scale of a business
if group before my promotes bit of check
if discovered at one point for Anna's a
trance key that makes it a five-point
lead for Alexandra cost on you and we
are potentially entering the last game
of this settlement right
and we have Patrick on the boards once
again and I used it already in this
match Bishop d3 once again with C 3 and
d 4 normally there is there are main
lines with d4 Knight c3 and so on but
this is what Alexandre is playing
against Patrick and it's nice I think to
play in pleased because then it's easier
you have to just place your pieces on
right squares and then see what happens
look I agree you it is going to be
difficult for enough to try to play for
a win in such a solid position but this
is the last game and then she will have
her chin singular as you said in blacks
5 points it's still doable so anna
starts well if she goes for a winning
streak at the very beginning that is
still possible the next session will be
half an hour of bula that is 1 minute
plus 1 second increment that's gonna be
fireworks then cherry on the top so stay
for that here with us and right after
the bullet we will interview most
players so that's what's coming up next
and we want to give a shout out to all
of you joining us o 5000 of you watching
the women speech Chess Championship
welcome everybody and thank you for be
here because it's amazing how many
chestnuts are out there being interested
in these event and I think that will
make us want to organize more and more
yeah tournaments shout out to all of you
it's definitely very important to fill
your supports to fill your feedback to
feel that you are enjoying the games
documentary so we're really happy and
we're really grateful that you joining
and you're with us you bear to us some
easy I mean I can't bear my stuff
because that was about to train and
develop the bishop state bishops is
still stuck on the background so that
was an issue the Queen came back to us
one interesting Square for the Queen you
don't normally see me there yeah you
don't and it's like the rook and the
Queen they can do
swapped the squares I like we don't have
one in says that they need as file is
open but I liked honest last move d5
really making sure that there is no eat
or easily and if after a poor she can
take on before I think that's what will
happen I would definitely take without
thinking here D take C for Bishop before
I would take a game this Bishop rookie
for and I would feel that I have two
bishops and Bishop d5 who likes the
Starks burn I don't know why she's
taking time hmm good question i it was
one don't really want to spend this much
time c5 that's also an interesting move
maybe much stronger than what I
recommend it because it's it might be
very dangerous for Alexandra now as the
King White King is really weakened you
don't want to open up everything though
I like to do want to take a light
squared Bishop I would sneeze sunburn
and I would say that I want to take a
fee on capital structure as you can see
the pawns are structured in a way that
normally there will be a bishop on g7 it
isn't there that gives some
possibilities for white on the dark
squares but also the White King is out
there in the open with a similar
situation there's no Bishop on G to put
the king is only do ya strength strange
decision from Alexandra to take on c5
let's black tape Bishop c5 wheelchair
and Lex black just developed very nicely
I like well what is what what black is
doing I didn't like it I really do so if
black can get one of their pieces
ideally the Queen or the bishop on the
long diagonal problematic for this is B
last game on the three first ones that
when the time is up so the result will
still count from this game but after
this one we will have
because I'm trying to be nice but she it
was she's back
Eastern the position there's a funny way
of doubling looks when there's a pole in
between but yeah that was a lot of
pressure on their cell phones yeah that
was certified yeah we would like to get
rid of this pond but unfortunately it's
impossible you can see right away and
then look everyone is very logical to
get the F while doing lose f7 I check
okay check I missed some chances you
know because I thought that with the
open files and the text she could have
some kind of attack going on but it's
not easy in place at all especially when
your opponent is Alexandra costanera who
is very good in place who is very fast
and who is one of their top players
indeed once again we have an opposite
colored bishop and which are not easy to
play for a win stand up in seconds left
for Ana he's being the last game I'm
expecting a Joe and then the bullet will
be touch for Anna but still doable if
she starts with the street so that will
be a five point lead for former women's
world champion as
Oh Staniel half an hour of blood games
and this is about qualifying to the next
stage the semi-finals of the women's
pictures championship the total prize
fund is twenty thousand dollars and the
winner will also make it to the overall
that is the husband he's not looking
after baby tactics that's how we can
become I hope he puts him to sleep this
game the players will go for short break
and so we are also going for a break
just to check on the road number four
and how he's doing baby sippy we'll be
back in a few minutes with the blue
portion don't go anywhere stay tuned
[Music]
Fisher random chess a game were
creativity is King and memorization
impossible 960 different back rank
configurations from the world's best
chess players into mere competitors
trying to outwit and outclass each other
with every unprepared move only one will
be worthy of the title of Fisher random
chess champion but the best part is that
champion could be you the Fisher random
Chess Championship will be unlike any
tournament ever held with a global
qualification system for the first time
ever
everybody truly has a chance to prove
themselves the best player in the world
at a chess variant are you a chess
artist worthy of the 11th world
champions admiration we're gonna find
out the tournament features open
qualifiers beginning on April 28th and
the title player qualifier stage
beginning in June over $300,000 Fabiano
Caruana Nakara Nakamura and world
champion Magnus Carlsen await you at the
later stages the Fisher random Chess
Championship title is there for the
taking
will you make a run at it go to F our
chests calm today to register and stay
tuned to chess comm for all the latest
news and updates regarding this historic
event it's the feed a world Fisher
random Chess Championship organized by
dude a.s and chess calm
[Music]
apparently the moment of the day and I
loved Alexandra's face she was like Oh
big smile on her face that's a great
reaction and ponder indeed she didn't
realize it Lucas honey but I think we
were more surprised by the situation yes
she was we will continue with the match
this is the last portion was beforehand
we want to remind you that today isn't
only about giving speeches championship
also the qualifier for the Fisher random
tournament will be hosted it's already
being held and there are more sessions
coming up Bigfoot will be hosting right
after our speed chess championship match
today so don't go anywhere if you want
more chest Fisher and I was really
exciting and the winner of the
qualification tournament will make it to
the big event when manga scores in the
field yeah I love Fisher Renton I played
one tournament in DC I think it was
almost pregnant so Danny helped me and I
wanted it's really really interesting so
very interesting to follow it make sure
that you follow it because it's great
fun I would love to play well we've been
doing commentary about three and a half
hours for L by there so I'll just have
dinner any more chocolate
oh yeah
[Laughter]
Karin see yeah that was your that was
supposed to be your kicks with
composition whether chocolates or
killers should be preferred and litovsky
needs to bounce back it's already a
fight with me for Ellison the coast and
there's only a half an hour session that
this is the final point of the match
this is the final part of the match and
we will have half an hour of bullet as
Anna mentioned it's going to be very
exciting because there is no more time
for anything just chess moves three
moves anything just don't be flat and we
have the normal very normal position I
like this position for black because
black already acheived thing f5 bishop
on v7 only think that black has to take
care is that this bishop on b7 is not
lost with a trick like Knight g5 but
Bishop f4 serves this thing so it's
dependent there and what white should
play is just before expand on the Queen
side before a4 and Queen b3 answer
afterwards but Queen b3 right away I'm
not really sure about Queen b3 I thought
that before would be more challenging
but then c5 could have been a food
response to before indeed I like some
guys a bit concerned about the
positioning seems to me she is under
slight pressure but not on the co it's
19 seconds for a Messalonskee so
Alexander one more time is doing very
well in terms of time management yeah
it's difficult it's difficult to play
bullets to use all these tribute tricks
if you're not familiar with the online
chess thing with chess palm and Anna is
definitely into just come because she's
wearing big chess one teacher yes I
don't know buddy because it was called
but earlier we saw that she is very
ended up just con pollo and and bleeding
for one of her students on her or his
birthday only to normal
yes yes she gave a check instead because
there's all sorts of like going but the
night bill
wait night takes my name is Gina sores
and now magic looking even the king is
trying to hide walk to the Queen side
living here but anything can happen I
mean obviously a free rookies free room
he has not taken yes chocolate is better
than carrots very bad also time ok
Aleksandra has 15 seconds versus 8
seconds but the position is already very
dangerous or it's gonna be male 18
working at 121 and if you have to Queen
f2
so if yet another point for Alexander
costing is of course a very tough match
for Anna's Adams if she's a four-time US
Women's Champion and as I don't see she
has been representing the people of the
United States one silver and bronze with
the team of America and the only people
on her board but her opponent has even
more titles for the women's world
champion accent the quest and you also
they only owe the Olympic gold she has
connected with her team Russia and no
individual a lot she is very talented
not only in chess but she has been
modeling she is an actress she played in
a movie Russian movie with
Pampa I asked her about it and yeah
she's simply very very strong it just
and she's very fast as we've seen in the
games she has a very hostile this is the
first time I'm thinking that Anna is
faster done Alexandre because Alexandre
has 47 seconds versus a minutes Anna is
doing very well did not use any second
one she only uses the ones
can she get this increment remember it's
a 1-minute first month second increment
game and now look at this how they
traded vicious but both weakening their
opponents Kings yeah though a seventh
one is gone and we cannot play with a
eight because of Queen B 7 bouquet - and
all Queen side fans would be gone so she
was forced to play Queen c7 sometimes
it's important that the position is also
good not only at the time but still
where it's okay for Anna staring field
some hope that she can bounce back but
it's getting harder and harder
yes such a big lead already for
Alexandra with only 25 minutes left from
the entire match this is looking great
for the form elements world champion and
if you guys are not fooling her to now
make sure to do so you can hover your
mouse over the screen if you're on a PC
and click on her channel support her
because she does stream very very on
page
we hope you'll also start streaming that
will be great yeah that will be great
and we need more streamers
oh alright so um what is happening here
I like that
B six ponies stopping all these three
points so far and we have three versus
two but it's a condom for black and same
colored Bishop this is going to be
tricky but Alexandra still needs to show
a big attack technique how to convert a
pawn if it's convertible a tool because
blacks roots are very active what's
great for Alexandra
even if she does not convert this she
will try what she should push she should
think this game as long as possible
yeah because she's already leaving with
six points so that means that draw is
not a disaster she of course would
prefer to win this yeah but anything but
losing is he will keep this huge
advantage that she selected yeah that is
true
and after this this can be tricky here
once again h5 phone is gone yeah this
yeah and resigns because she wants to
play more games is needed
there's a limited time only 23 minutes
left so she wants to go for more games
that have a new chance yeah
and now we have ey e e4 c5 final I was
waiting to mention already to see this
opening again the Sicilian yeah kidding
we know that they like this fine line
yeah it's enough we find very
interesting king of wonky g'wan engaged
to some kind of thing
why King G 1 and why not Kim G - maybe
it was mostly we don't know yeah let's
hope it's preparation because it looks
strange
it looks really strange yeah it does so
on Aviv's
gives up her to bishops advantage what
she gets for it I don't know nice at
frequently I think is ok for whites this
Bishop doesn't seem to be much better
than the night but after castle I really
like blacks position yeah I really do of
it now that you have secured your king
and at the same time you put pressure on
the t3 background for it was not
possible to say that on there for like
cushions before and that opens the c5 of
the kingdom g1 is still blocking the
room they were yeah I think that it was
really ma sleep with Kim Ji Won King g2
and because PG 2 was way more natural
and more logical now I still like that
because I think that Bishop is a bit
stronger than the night
objectively it should be equal there
shouldn't be anything going on but it
still upon pony so funny even if he
doubled its upon yes and once again
Aleksandra who is leaving with 7 points
in seven points if she wins this game
8 points I don't see I can come back
from an age for this advantage yeah
eight point is almost Laurent
I don't know probably you need and our
you need to bury Twilight tired
Alexandra continued to get back those
points which doesn't seem to be the case
Alexandra of course has been preparing
for the Women's candidates tournament
it's coming up in just three days in
Kazan she will be competing in order to
qualify for her so well-deserved match
she will want to win back the title of
the national champion and that's what
she was focusing well not all night
Jasmine place but all the preparation
that goes into playing in the candidates
tournament is showing down the ball
because it's a lot of effort in chess in
general yeah and she's been world
champion from 2008 and 2010 we had not
we have a different system we have
candidates tournament and it's very
interesting to see how it's going to
work for ladies because there was system
like every year was World Championship
and even if you didn't take part you
would lose your title even if he didn't
play so I really like this change and
candidates ornaments should be exciting
Alexandra is the participant of the
tournament she will try her best to do
and qualify to play the world champion
from China Juve and June mm-hmm then you
can follow if you want to support
Alexandra and make sure to click on that
channel over your mouse over the screen
and follow Alexander constant news which
channel in terms of this game once again
we see only 5 seconds left for Anna I'm
getting a heart attack and another
resignation
yeah well points two points and the
bishop that's a lot of material so and
it was for a Mexican but eight-point
lead already but it's just Queen yeah
eight point lead
we can probably say that it's clear that
Alexandra will win this match but as we
had in the first message match it's
important not to lose all your games not
to relax because there is of course
price confer for these matches well
wiener
means thousand dollars and another
thousand dollar is divided by percentage
in these animals need to win points also
for increasing her prize for today's
participation very important point
therefore even in the materials decided
it doesn't matter how much you earn of
course it's always nice to know how many
chocolates you can buy basically for
carrots all right so what we're we are
having here nice battery on the a1 h8
diagonal now there is a bit fragile made
so black has to do something about it so
far I feel that Allah is in nearly never
again a under big pressure not only by
time but also positions are difficult to
play and somehow Alexander's strategy of
and opening choices are working very
well for her and exactly in this
position for example now main has to go
to c7 not to drop the b6 ma and it gets
under beam now 9c3
is a very tricky move because after
Bishop g2 there might be tricks
connected with 95 or 95 and after E 5
which is tiny bits mysterious move for
me because I would o tape on was hanging
sorry yeah just trying to cash in on
this pin on the street right well Queen
b6 and you need to make moves like that
it's already here looking suspicious
with a discovered attack nice things b6
the Queen is honey
the rook is hanging and his position is
collapsing Alexander parsnip is on fire
she's bending excellently she only made
it very few mistakes and it's just
incredible she only just blundered at
one game Lucas honey and there were a
very few suspicious moments were passing
that she's been controlling the whole
match tactical vision hundred and meters
and all and for chess skills of course
I'll tell her she's the world number 6 :
Leon the classic waiting list and one of
the candidates to challenge jewel engine
as we mentioned already yeah this is
going to be a participant for Alexandra
but we still want to see Ana bouncing
back because she's a fighter she's been
doing very well she would deserve more
points in ice team because she had many
many winning positions but yes depending
on this one blunder yeah and when were
under time pressure
I think biggest problem for Ana was that
she didn't really manage how to devise a
correct time where do you think and what
kind of decisions to take but yeah it's
an online chess it's very important
before
please matches and for tactical pigeons
to be fast there are a lot of factors in
online chess and leads chance generally
and Alexandra did perfect she she was
and I think is stronger in this match in
this particular match and it's great for
her because candidates tournament is
coming up and to show openness that she
is prepared she's in good shape yeah
she's in great shape and heading into
the candidates starting in three days
that's why we keep referring to it
Alexandra is going to Kazan probably
right after this match is over yeah and
we'll have tomorrow the match of
Valentina goon universes Irina crash
Valentina is also one of the
participants of the candidates
tournament that's going to be exciting
but let's take care of this game now
what is going on I think Alexandra is
doing a game very fine I like the team
on the a 1hh diagonal that's why night
support happens now she can actually
relax and she can just accept choice
any moments yeah well she's such a
fighter she goes for III are very simple
she wants to win and win and win she's
not going for any job yeah and other
once again has eight seconds 28 seconds
for Alexandra is very difficult look at
these bishop manner is very nice
it was not really anything on be silent
because of a free phone and Bishop c8
Bishop f5 now Bishop ease into the game
Oh Knight c3 93 nice tactic Frank
there was a veteran columns of the night
untouchable yeah and after 93 I still
like blacks position even though
material is equal but I think that black
is doing fine just sheet should not take
money to England he happened after the
king was most here so there's no a bad
friend problem more trees are happening
the pawns are the second on the board
still tricky with the rook and Knight
going against the white king but I
believe Anna has devised the most
difficult stage on this game she did
yeah she did and this probably will be
draw which Alexandra I think doesn't
mind now still pressure light has won
the g7 pawn did this attack on the r7
horn and she can pick up the age for one
of them yeah that's was a bit unexpected
so I think I should stay more often
that's to be an easy draw because I
never never guessed whenever I said is
something I don't know we are great
addictions yeah smarter just shut up
smarter chess and fishery is gonna put
trying to give shout out and the bishop
is gone the H point still alive and as a
possible why why oh my god that was bad
luck really very bad luck for Anna's
Adamski who had actually winning
position but yeah it was a fortnight and
Anna is losing on time a game where she
was supposed to win and not lose that
Bishop well sometimes when things go
downhill it's really going down here you
know the wheel speed up yeah
unfortunately that's what's happening to
an apparently yeah it's not easy to
bounce back and it's bullet a lot of
blunders
she had a chance to bounce back but it's
still 10 point
lead I don't think she can catch up 12
minutes to finish the match it's really
not so much time to catch up and I don't
think ty what happens how it will happen
no this is already a ten point lead for
Assam with only 12 minutes left from the
bullet that is the final settlement of
the match and remember that the winner
of today will get a thousand dollars and
the other thousand of the prize fund for
today's match is divided in terms of the
percentage which is looking great for
elections at the moment yeah it's very
important so yeah one more game we have
where I think Ana is under pressure
because I generally like this structure
for white it's Dutch thermal structure
and black managed to get out with her
Bishop out soon h5 which is kind of the
main point you don't want to have Bishop
on c5 but it's very difficult to play
this because white has Center White has
squares and somehow I always like to
play against stone wall I really do that
I also prefer to try to make those
squares weaker with the exposed position
because of the structure but here I
think it won't be that much another one
but those pork nine get you 40 most
because this is another factor got it oh
[Music]
my god it's it's difficult to all these
double attacks a lot of opportunities
missed by ana and a lot of blunders in
please I guess if it's like cool blunder
more because there is no way you're
playing for three hours and you don't
have thunder so it's totally fine the
blunders but yeah it seems like Ana he's
the one who plundered a lot of times and
is now 10 points down points that's huge
she will try to win the last couple of
games because that will at least give
her a bigger prize for today for a split
and
percent according to spec's percentage
splitting the $1,000 that it's the seven
thousand one two thousand a million is
so complicated but it's not this
complicated
the more you mean the better yeah that's
the conclusion actually it works like
this in one fit such a big moral I know
Tyler - Oh Sicilia on the board one of
the final games yeah and ten minutes to
go before the end of the match and there
is 11 point lead by Alexandra Costigan
which is impossible to catch up in ten
minutes even if you win in a minute it's
really impossible so we can definitely
say that Alexandra pasta will be the
winner of this match so she will qualify
into semi-finals
as well as a winner Danielle Ian indeed
in the last match and she was the
underdog this time they've paper it wins
them mesh what happens in this game I do
like whites
I do like whites position and I do like
what's going on but Deidre pond is a bit
weak so we cannot completely focus on
attack now I'm just realizing that so
far Alexandra has won all the blood
games which has never happened
oh yeah is that I hope that is true
because um I'm just a little amazed that
yes how difficult it is to have a
perfect square Y by Del T on games in a
mother si that's impressive
all games 100% score Wow yeah insurance
all the games this will be the first
time ever in speed chess history and
that is all speech has champions yeah
because given speeches yeah yeah a lot
of games like we have speed Junior
Championship we have a Women's
Championship now but we had men's speed
men's championship open section and
never happened hundred percent school
Wow can she leave it Western I dunno
this is the question is not the question
in Hormuz winning the match we know it
moving on to the next stage but will she
make it a perfect score that does not
the chat with anything a shout out to
all of you thousands of you joining us
today
whatever my speeches championship me so
thank you for being here and for your
support this is the first ever we must
be Chess Championship but definitely not
the last one here on just the phone no
no definitely not and we are really
happy to be here and to be covering and
hosting the event thank you all of you
for joining and it was still great match
just we had very exciting match the
first match because the score was level
but Alexandra showed a great skill of
playing she's very fast she is very
tough opponents and still in a hats
translates to bounce back in the match
indeed now this position is still very
dangerous you see that the White King is
struggling
what are those moves under friendly
didn't have many squares and isn't it
just trapped yeah it is just one more
conference in the cosmic she's going for
the perfect scoring bullet
Wow six minutes we will have an
interview after this and we will
definitely ask Alexandra if she expected
to have perfect score in bullets that
that's that will make history of speech
chest and so don't go anywhere we will
have short interviews with the players
yeah after the work is done so six
moments of this segment and that's it
the end of the match can accent of in
all her games in the next six minutes
that is the question now wow I don't
know
I think how many games probably maximum
three games they can play in six minutes
I think so I don't know so will she win
coming six game in three games in six
minutes
Wow at least three games and thank you
smoker just for creating a poor weather
chocolate or carrots are better food for
chess players I think everyone should in
the chat to be really important for I
think it's more important than any
elections
make sure you vote you need your voice
to be heard
all right I need to know sure Kara team
um do we have
I think canister hammer should have
character not see lost carrots Oh
careless no this is one of the final
games of the bullet bill Alexander may
be the perfect scores over she's doing
very well not this particular game but
in general the tendency that she came
back from difficult positions what is
that might exceed me move yeah
what was that light takes III just the
rooks goes on right our three hours I
think anything can happen antsy I you
can just mouse leaves or anything just
it's very tiring for players because
even we are tired we don't play we're
not under pressure but it's tiring to
play for three hours and I think that is
the reason of such moves like Knight c3
but yeah it is a crushing score and
probably the biggest score I think yeah
in the Windows Features championship
this will be the biggest score of course
we haven't seen many matches this is the
second
but I would think that this could be the
biggest difference in terms of the two
players overall because still have
tomorrow's match Lessman everywhere
tomorrow as Valentin who universes Irina
crushed and then on the 30th of May we
have the next match then is between hari
Carnevale and Maurice debois the winner
of those matches
today's tomorrow's and the one on the
30th of May will make it to the
semi-finals those four players will face
each other
yeah then we have the coin toss yeah the
finals it will be interesting who can
make it for two finals definitely
Alexandre question it will be the one
who will try her best to be still there
and to go to finals because it's clear
that she is winning this match she is
but the question remains will SH maybe
the earth to square which has never
happened
Oh interesting she was running game yeah
but this is winning because they came
he's in the air King c3 and King bee to
another wing for Alexander's means that
she has 200% she won all bullet games
this is incredible it is impressive two
minutes and 40 seconds to go to finish
the match so it means that we will have
time only for one maximum two games yeah
and if she wins next game she will have
100 percent which will be she will make
the history nobody ever did it Wow not
even lengua spells I'm not even okona
her and no one has ever won all games in
the bread which is just insane it's
incredible it's incredible it's so
impressive and it's so stressful for the
one who is losing I know I feel really
served for Anna is Anna - so I feel bad
for every anti in the world they are
losing but apart from that she's been
doing really well at the beginning of
the match he doesn't deserve such a huge
difference I think that sums are really
playing the way better but is this the
score that we saw
that would come out of those games
really not know I thought that it would
be really close match and I thought
Alexander was still favorite because she
is very strong experienced and she's
dreaming she has her own channel so you
can see somewhere there I'm against
these things I will show I love with my
mom so become it five years ago missed a
baby's neck face yeah that's just gonna
have her channel please don't have her
channel oh yeah
pressure on me but yeah another game we
have so this is sorry it was my bad that
I wasn't showing the current position so
what we have here okay again pawn up for
Alexander constant it really looks like
she is going for another we will she
make hundred percent but the cons
actually disappeared I should never
predict anything
you are just jinxing the players I feel
like but this is it the lost game
finally the bullet segment and if some
do means this can be really told how
many came she has won the sting is this
reckon game might shoot old but Anna has
been really on that down here I can't
stop it just you keep rolling like a
snowball this should be a draw
yeah but 17 seconds 20 seconds the piece
should be though if this is a draw it
won't be hundred percent for Alexandra
pasta new but still nobody want so many
games in bullet I think true she was
still where she was to have the record
that she won almost every game except
for this one this will be a job or can
Anna win this that will be I see for
Anna how she feels about the match it
would be here if she wins the final game
and then giving an interview is somewhat
better than losing no I'm not sure
because I like the Hans on b5 and CC so
a nice plane to win and I had a chance
to win the last game yeah and I think
that's what will happen
she's she has also more time on Clark
and P time is up so this is the last
game already
queeny's on the board and this really
looks like that Anna's gonna win the
last game and it will be twenty to eight
points 12 points for Alexandra see ya
still of course a massive victory for
the chest Queen what a bullet final
rundown she had won every single game up
until this moment where it was a Jewish
who can get maybe she wanted even more
damage oh yeah I got missing this one
but still what a record by Queen to
Queens on the board and yes it is Anna
won the last game so there is no more
game time is up and Aleksandra one and
match with an impressive for twenty to
eight really impressive it will go for a
real quick technical break in order to
get ready for the interview with the
players don't go anywhere and while
you're on a break make sure to follow
this ladies Chris channel I see a link
in the chat because she will start
streaming next week all right follow me
see you guys soon
[Music]
welcome back everybody this is beef
final segment of today's match of the
has beat Chess Championship
congratulations to Alexander coast and
you for winning the match with such an
impressive for an ANA thank you so much
for the epic fight we will have plenty
of questions about me well and I also
want to congratulate Alexandra a
sad poor it wasn't indeed impressive
score but how did it happen Wow such
gains so many how did you feel actually
to play online cleats and what are your
first thoughts both of you well I'm not
a hundred percent new to the online
chess I've been playing quite a bit in
my life so nothing particular it's what
what was new is a match format because I
haven't really you know played such a
long match because usually if you play
online against one opponent I don't know
somehow I get bored after four games and
I just quit and here we needed to play
for three and a half hours it was not
boring I must say the time flew very
fast so I'm happy about it because I I
was afraid that I will you know at some
point I will just be bored and mistakes
will come so you entered
absent you have a positive and did you
think that that will help and how do you
consider your chances maybe like you
know like lawn chairs like lawn games
but I think I'm not sure if it has good
score in Billy's game I know Alexander
is very strong blitz player so I didn't
I didn't consider that I have good
chances in the match because I know how
strong he is and especially on online
chess checkers probably more experience
and I only need to practice more and
especial in the end I would let
extremely tight and I hope
I could do better in one minute chess so
it was very chance and thank you
Alexandra for good fight and I had
cylinders by the end of the mission just
start playing better than in the
beginning yeah doctor we were actually
following the weapon also and you are
looking up at the camera and then you
were you started laughing at some point
can you tell us what was happening yeah
my husband just arrived so can you get
to it we have been going through the
database and Alexandra you have played
over 2,000 blade and blood games
combined on chance calm and did you I'm
sure you weren't aware of the number but
you have played plenty of games did you
think that that will give you a good
chance going into not just today's match
but the Women's Championship in general
well that's a bit tricky because we're
playing with sacramental time and it's
different than just playing you know
online three three minutes or bullet
games it's different when you play with
seconds additional seconds that means
that you need to be concentrated till
they till end of every game because
there was one blunder I blundered to
rook and if you blunder here then the
game is over
while when you play like online was no
increment you always have chances you
know I've lost hundreds of games when I
was winning but just somebody flagged me
and that's considered to be normal but
somehow in this speed Chess Championship
was to try to play chess I mean
logically to finish the game but of
course I mean any I think experience
helps but it's I think it's absolutely
different than playing a match on like a
3d like real pieces because you your
perception I mean you see the board
differently and sometimes you
some moves that you would never miss
playing like normal pieces so that's
that's a bit different but of course
experience helps in any field and in
this particular case it helped me as
well
yeah we know that you are a very
experienced you're streaming as well and
we've heard actually that you're going
to like I consider in to look like more
internet that's nice to hear so we still
have some hoops that Anna will be
streaming we do have possibility that
you are wearing the chairs that come
follow a little note on your t-shirt can
you tell us about that I want to
congratulate my student air from Texas
she was a for those days is what's your
birthday yesterday and I want to wish
her like a lot of success in chess and
everything here if you can hear me say
make sure that I would love to have such
coaches it's so great that you had the
little notes and that was for yours I
was also impressed that you are wishing
your student happy birthdays through the
stream yeah and I just would like to say
about practice that I tried to practice
like one minus plus one seconds but
nobody wanted to play but I think I mean
if you lower your rating I mean you can
always find you put the level I mean you
won't
to play usually that's what happens I
mean to me I put the level I mean the
rating is very high so yes if you want
to find someone with I mean this
particular time control you should use
lower it is my husband to practice with
me that's really nice
Alexandra are you qualified into semi
finals and tomorrow there will be a
match between Valentina Lumina and Irina
crush though you will play the winner of
that match
can I ask you who do you prefer to play
that's difficult to answer because of
course I mean if we speak about like if
it would be a normal like life match of
course Valentina would be a favorite but
online I'm not I'm not hundred percent
sure especially since I mean Valentina
is also going to play in the candidate
shows she's already
she might be already in Kazan you know
she might already feel like not giving
too much energy does this match and
somehow it might well it's gonna be
interesting I'm sure I will I will be
watching it tomorrow night and but
what's good it's good happen after Kazan
that that will be like you know a breath
of fresh air I'm sure because I mean
classical chest for me it's it's how to
put it it's always it's it's not really
a pleasure
I mean it's especially online blitz I
can enjoy it I can relax you know I can
have fun
well cos Anya and the candidates
consider more like a hard work and you
know that work that you do
I mean sometimes it can go badly and
there is nothing you can do I mean you
you try your best but how it will go
can expect well when you play blitz no
one game went wrong okay no problem
there's gonna be another one and and
always you can always try your luck in
the next games well okay cuz I need
different so I'm I'm looking forward to
tomorrow much tomorrow as much I'm gonna
watch it and then after Kazan yeah we'll
certainly have fun and enjoy very much
into the candidates that's definitely
they importance tournament that's coming
up for you as you were already world's
champion we know that you want to get
back your crown well I want you know I
wouldn't say that I have like this
particular goal in mind what I want to
do is to play well and you know to do
well in the tournament and then there's
gonna be only one winner and okay great
great very strong players so we'll see
how it goes
but it's gonna be a very tension tough
tournament depends if you can let us
know about your future tournaments
I don't know any nearer any chess event
in your future I will be teaching many
chests camps in the United States and
teaching I'm teaching in Connecticut
says like to use like boot camp it's
just some tennis camp and like tennis
might be might be good for my daughter
professional tennis coaches as well okay
we'll see maybe for the knot for this
summer because it's already planned but
for the next I will keep it in mind yes
I know because I think that everyone is
interested in the chestbounce
I would go I would go I would take
Daniel and I would just I would just be
there thanks so much to both of you for
participating and once again accent uh
congratulations on qualifying to the
next day - good luck for the candidates
we will be watching and we will be back
tomorrow with the match your rameshan
Valentina clean up vs iron across we
will say goodbye to the players for now
and then we are back after a very quick
break for a summary of the match yeah
thank you for your fight thank you and
congratulation Klum thank you and
goodbye
thank you congratulations and good luck
in Kazan thank you bye
[Music]
what an epic Maria bursting out of
laughter because the carrot versus
chocolate fight is still an ongoing
battle between sub economy and better I
will end up in the basement
oh yeah what a match Alexandre she was
in great shape she crushed with
impressing 20 points vs. 8 but Anna did
show some fighting chance to be missed a
lot of opportunities it's true but it's
difficult as players mentioned this is
very different format it's very
different from real chess and you have
to be here for a long time so it's
difficult but congratulations to
Aleksandra kostadin who qualified into
semi-finals indeed and as a lesson
dimension she normally doesn't play
these many games against the same
opponent she says after four games I get
bored this match was exciting for her as
well and definitely it goes to show that
experience matters Alexandra's higher
rated than and above all 9 chest it's a
different world as over the board
tournaments and exams having played over
2,000 games of Jessica how many have you
guys played on she spend a lot of time
there and the problem actually for Anna
was that she couldn't practice and there
was a very nice tea from Alexandra that
she should lower the rating to get to
the challenge accepted and I'm sure that
many of you would like to play and also
bounced it yeah I would love to play and
apart from that we really want to thank
everybody for joining us this has been
such a pleasure to stream for you guys
this has been only the second match of
the women speak championship tomorrow we
are back with another epic battle
another Russia vs. you guys match yeah
Valentina Galina is higher rated but
Irina crushed room is her fight for
short for the qualification spot yeah
can you
as revenge for today's match we will
know that tomorrow but the fun is not
over tonight as we have Fisher random
qualifier coming up right after the show
so right after it make sure you stay
there will be Fisher random qualifier I
love fish around us I would love to play
but I decided I would rather have dinner
and eat chocolate
so my try freeze I like Fisher and them
but chocolate but make sure to watch it
Bigfoot will be hosting event and it is
for a very important qualification spot
into the big guns
hi that is the world championship of
Fisher random in the oceans yes it is
everybody will be there and one of you
will be there the person is precise
today yeah so good luck to all the
participants there I'm sure it's gonna
be great sure enjoy and apart from that
before we say goodbye we are going to
read how nice they get us we are going
to go back to last night she's got an
amazing stream upcoming boathouse
potentially I've seen her swimming but
not sure today's all difficult but she's
extremely good and very difficult I'm
very bad in that how this she's gonna
sling some podcast today so we are going
over to her channel come with us join us
and see you tomorrow at the same time
same place topic on Idol with that with
Valentina universe is even across
another derby
that you don't want to miss see you all
tomorrow thank you for being here see
you thank you everybody for joining and
thank you for being here see you
tomorrow bye